i there's pink cards in the back in the
anteroom make sure you fill out a pink
card so it can get up to me so i know to
call your name and have you come testify
no not that i see yet
all right it'd be in the appointed time
at nine o'clock i'm going to call a
committee into in the order
um we'll start the committee by the
saying the pledge of allegiance if you
please rise up
i pledge allegiance to the flag
of the united states of america
to the republic for which it stands
one nation under god
indivisible with liberty justice is a
problem
so make sure everybody's at the right
committee here which i'm sure you are
this is the committee to study the
policy of medical interventions and
immunizations
i'm going to start the committee meeting
off the same way i've started the last
four office just to let people know
there are approximately 30 32 bills that
have been filed
here at the state house this year
relative to the conversation of on four
topics and that is coveted
masking mandates and vaccinations there
are 30 current bills pending here you go
tim
there are 30 33 bills that are currently
pending
one of these
there you go thank you
all right i'm going to run through the
titles just real quick so everyone's
familiar with the bills that are
existing so if there's anything any of
them that are of interest of you
you can go look them up further some of
the language is not online yet
ols the office of legislative services
will have
the
bills probably online by first of
december mid december at the latest
before our january start date for the
next session so again i'm just going to
run through the titles of these bills
relative requiring the coven 19
vaccination for school attendance
requiring the new hampshire attorney
general to empower and panel a covid 19
grand jury to investigate events
related to the coven 19 pandemic
relative the state's grants for
researching the effects on the human
body of the coven 19 vaccine
requiring post-secondary institutions to
accept religious and medical exemptions
from vaccine requirements
requiring an audit of the new hampshire
vaccine association
making the state vaccine registry an
opt-in program relative to the
exemptions from vaccine mandates
relative to the exemptions from school
vaccine mandates
relative to students attending public
schools that mandate the wearing of face
masks without emergency orders in place
limiting the authority of the department
of health and human services to mandate
vaccinations and relative to the
quarantine costs
relative to state enforcement of the
federal vaccine mandates
relative to medical mandates adopted by
employers
relative to employee protections from
covet 19 in the workplace
prohibiting the state and local
governments from adopting certain
mandates in response to coba 19 and
prohibiting employers in places of
public accommodation from discriminate
from discrimination
relative to the procedure of withdrawing
from the vaccine registry
requiring the department of health and
human services to maintain certain
records relative to the vaccine registry
expanding the prohibition against
discrimination based on the individual's
election not to participate in the state
vaccine registry
prohibiting the department of health and
human services from requiring vaccine
passports for services
prohibiting the higher education
institutions receiving state funds from
requiring face mass and covenanting
vaccinations for attendance
proclaim proclaiming the first monday of
march has covered 19 victims and
survivors day
relative to a little limited liability
for personal injury resulting from or
related to exposure to coven 19
relative to unemployment benefits from
employees terminated for refusing to
comply with vaccine mandates
relative to unenforceability of
non-complete non-compete agreements upon
termination of an employee for
non-compliance with vex with a vaccine
mandate
relative vaccine mandates for government
contractors relatives of financial
responsibility for employer-mandated
coven-19 testing of employees
prohibiting the school districts from
mandating covet 19 vaccines for school
attendance prohibiting certain employers
from requiring covet 19 vaccination as a
condition of employment
relative to eligibility for workers
compensation for adverse reaction for
mandatory covet-19 vaccinations
requiring the full food and drug
administration approval of vaccines
relative to coven 19 health and safety
policies at the new hampshire performing
arts venues
relative to school district policies on
facial masks and students in schools and
lastly requiring an independent audit
and needs assessment regarding
covenanting preparedness and long-term
care facilities nurses homes the
veterans homes
sorry i can't read the whole thing
and making an appropriation therefore so
those are the 32 bills that are
currently pending before the legislature
that have been filed were filed in
september
those bills will all get public hearings
and they'll be assigned to the
appropriate committee some of those are
senate bills
and some are not okay everybody's
well i'll see you anyway
can when you guys go find one of the
audio guys see if they can figure out
what that feedback's from anyway so
we're going to open up public testimony
um on this again the the task of this
committee is the is to look at the
policy of medical intervention and
immunizations as it relates to gov
governmental policies
and making a recommendation uh based on
our
our committee and our study here so
first up will be representative tim
horgan
well thank you thank you very much thank
you very much mr chair so i'm president
timothy horrigan so i'm on um
so i wanted to speak up for the vaccines
i mean i realize
not everyone can take them not everyone
will want to take them but i think um
something has been very much lost in the
debate ironically is the fact that the
virus is extremely dangerous vastly more
dangerous than the
than the vaccines they're not 100 safe
but nothing in life is 100 safe but if
we'd um
if we hadn't developed the vaccines if
we hadn't taken
the various emergency measures which i
think should have been tougher
we would have
we would have lost even more people than
we did and as it is this is the uh
biggest catastrophe in terms of numbers
killed since the civil war um and so one
of the
even though we're sort of in denial
about it it's a
it's a major catastrophe worldwide and i
happen
i i
i happen to represent durham which has a
number of uh
a number of uh
chinese residents from from china
because of uh they're studying at unh
and they um
their country took it
much more seriously i mean they're very
different from us and it's an impressive
country i don't want to live there but
they uh you know they were very
aggressive about and what they did uh
whatever else you might think about the
way they do things it was uh if
it worked you know like which is you
know
you know nearly universal testing and um
and rolling out the vaccines quickly and
stuff so
i have
i have several
bills i guess you could describe as
pro-vaccine bills um there's
um two bills about the medical
freedom and immunizations act i think
which one
which i'm just co-sponsoring with a
member from keane which just carves out
a
was
there's several exemptions already
carved out so now it also says that
college
that colleges and universities are also
exempt from that from that law so they
can require vaccines if they want to and
the
private institutions i believe have
all required vaccines unh
because of the federal contractor is
going along voluntarily they think it's
a good idea as far as i can tell
with uh getting universal vaccine or or
testing
i've also
also got one i also have a bill in there
which
which says that employers cannot forbid
employees from getting
vaccinated and i don't
know of any cases where employers have
tried to forbid employees from getting
vaccinated but i do know
i do know for them there was a private
school in florida that got a lot of uh
they got a lot of attention for firing
all its vaccinated faculty members and
um getting rid of his facul the
vaccinated students because they
believed incorrectly that
getting vaccinated made you more
dangerous to those around you which is
you know exactly the opposite of the
truth and
and so uh and then
and then um i also want to mention
something that i worked on years ago
which is somewhat
tangentially related but it was the bill
about
buffer zones around
reproductive health facilities and i
remember the time i was aware that
there were some religious groups who
objected to
vaccinations and i had heard from you
know we've had the anti-vaxxers who
believe also incorrectly there's mercury
and other dangerous things in the
vaccines
um
and i did uh
i did ask reproductive health clinics
and also then other health if they ever
had any trouble problem with people
picketing or interfering with other
with vaccinations also some religious
groups are also against blood
transfusions they said
they'd never had any problems until the
covet vaccine um
the coveted vaccine
so covet 19 came along there wasn't
there wasn't this vast
public outcry there weren't large
numbers of religious groups who opposed
vaccinations so somehow
and i don't really know the answer to it
somehow i think a lot of people i think
somehow this has become uh
at least
at least a position that's
taken a lot gotten a lot of attention
i'm not sure how many how many people
actually
follow it because the vast majority of
people i think are quietly
taking the precautions they need to
protect themselves against the pandemic
including being vaccinated but
back then back then when we when we
passed that law
um there was
you know we i did we did ask whether
there was any need for put vex you know
vaccine clinics in there and they said
no no no there's never been any problems
so there's a now that there is a problem
you may want to consider
enacting a similar
assumer protection for vaccine clinics i
know they've had some problems in
california with
people
with protesters trying to block um
people from getting vaccines and and
tests so
um
anyway so i guess i'll just close by
saying that there is a i think the
majority people are in favor of the
vaccines they
want as many of their neighbors to be
vaccinated
most people
are very afraid of covid they know how
dangerous it is and
they also know that
the vaccines and the
other uh
and the other precautions we've been
taking
are necessary and are effective so i
think
i think you should listen to the
silent majority more than the more
outspoken minority
understand why they're
i mean i understand why everybody's
upset about this and scared but i think
you should listen to the silent um
anti-covet
and pro-vaccine majority on this thanks
will you take questions
sure why not sure any questions from the
committee
i'm going to ask one because
i'll ask
representative leon so
whenever somebody uses the 750 thousand
dollar that thousand death toll that's
in there and i'm i'm a kind of a numbers
and data guy and i guess my question was
are you aware that there are over seven
thousand deaths reported in that total
that are from self-inflicted injuries
and poisoning but being classified as
covet deaths
i have not have not heard that
particular statistic i
um i don't really
mean some of those some of those people
were probably severely depressed and
suicidal even before covent and that was
just one of the things that set them
over the top so i'm not um
even though
nobody enjoyed being locked down nobody
i mean i don't like wearing these masks
i don't think the number of people have
killed themselves because of that is
i think that's a fraction of those
who've been actually killed by the virus
so um i'll
look into that i was not aware of that
statistic i don't know where it comes
from so i can't comment further than
that it's from the cdc website and they
reported deaths in their causations of
deaths
that they classify as covet deaths and
then have a secondary classification and
it's again self-inflicted injury and
poisonings um and how many did you say
once again over seven thousand okay
that's still just one percent of the
seven hundred thousand so i mean i'll
look into it but
um i don't think
just like that you're not really uh
so follow-up question so again
um
relative to vaccines vaccine mandates i
i think it was your testimony that this
has never been an issue before and i
think that probably the crux of the
factor is the mandate in and of itself
in that before
um
citizens had the right to through
various exemption models to get
exemptions and and now those models are
being taken away those rights are being
taken away to have exemptions we heard
testimony from a nurse yesterday monday
that said that while she was giving a
religious exemption for the purposes of
an influenza vaccine at her healthcare
facility when it came to covid they
decided that she wasn't entitled to a
religious exemption and took it away and
fired her
so does that sound like a reasonable
course of action that we want our
businesses looking at how religious
individuals are and whether they qualify
or not for a religious exemption is that
what we should be putting our businesses
in the middle of
well the
businesses also have a vested interest
in not killing off their employees
especially now there's a labor shortage
or their customers
[Music]
this is a disease that's
much more dangerous than the seasonal
flu and also of course the seasonal flu
i think is more dangerous than we
realize too there are
actually a fair number of people get
killed by it every year but um in terms
of that specific case um
i was not at the i was not at the
hearing yesterday also having a way of
verifying if what she said was was
accurate or not
i can say though that that one we had
when we had a debate about religious
procedures the
issue of vaccinations did not come up
and certainly the mainstream religious
groups who were
opposed
to the buffer zone and there are others
who in favor of it but those are opposed
to it never brought up vaccinations at
all so they've never been you know they
those particular
those groups the roman catholic church
and mostly the evangelical movement
there
they were not opposed to vaccines then
there's certainly a catholic church
which i'm a member of although not a
very good member of it's actually
actively
pro-vaccine and also
made a point when the pandemic started
of uh you know of uh taking the
emergency measures they had for example
the dramatic thing where the pope
addressed
it
did his easter address in saint peter's
square and he pointedly had
nobody in the square except for one
cameraman so certainly uh
so certainly my particular church that i
was brought in is actually very much
pro-vaccine and there's
so i'm not sure there was an answer in
there but okay okay um
you know my question was strictly around
is this what we are businesses doing is
determining whether somebody's religious
enough to be entitled to a religious
exemption from a vaccine that's my
question should businesses be put in
that position and don't you agree that
if we put them in that position it
creates then a follow-up civil rights
problem for them if they should deny a
medical exemption and say whole classes
of people can no longer work in my
facility because of their religious
beliefs don't you think that because
becomes a problem well there's a
constitutional right to freedom of
religion there
is no constitutional right to
spread a communicable disease so
i
you know it's up to the businesses
businesses decide what their policies
should be and i think probably most of
them would like to have their
most of them would like to have as many
of their employees as possible be
vaccinated um and bearing in mind there
probably are some legitimate cases where
they or they can't but for whatever
reason
number of people who are claiming
religious exemptions seem to be vastly
larger than it was back when the worst
thing we had to worry about was say you
know the seasonal flu and so forth
representative leon do you have a
question
you asked what i was going to ask thank
you thank you thank you representative
morgan thank you and i'm just speaking
for myself with my opinions and i i
understand where you're coming from so
thank you
next up is kelly malloy
so i do want to speak in facts and
address some specifics that are in the
new hampshire constitution
and
the constitution for the america united
states of america but first i i'd like
to actually
take us all back a little bit
i'd like to take you back to being a
teenager and if you can remember what
that was like
so for some of us that's a long time ago
and maybe it's easier to remember or
think about if you have a child that's
currently a teenager
i think that our nation
is very much
like a teenager right now
there's a little bit of rebelliousness
going on
there's a lot of
what i think is best
i know best
i know better than
those who came before me
i want to make up my own rules
do things my way
and i think we all know where that goes
right as we grow and mature
we realize that some of those rules and
structures that were put in place by our
parents
were done so lovingly
with wisdom
with experience of having been there
before
and not out of cruelty
or ignorance
or not being cool
so
teenagers often think that's whatever
whatever is now whatever is present is
best right their music their clothing
their culture
and what i would say is that
when we mature we become adults
ourselves we often find that we go back
to our parents structure and standards
and their beliefs right for our own
children because we realize there was
validity there
assuming you had
good moral standing parents
so in the case of this country this
nation
i looked to our forefathers
as our parents
and what i see is that they put
a very specific structure in place
our constitution
not just to limit government which was
definitely the intention right was to
limit
government
but i believe it was also to protect us
okay to give us
that compass those guidelines so that we
didn't go completely off course from the
intention of this nation
right the intention of those founding
documents was liberty
that was the aim that was the goal
right
so with that in mind i want to point out
a few things
one being
what was just mentioned the freedom of
religion that is provided for in the new
hampshire constitution
as well as our federal constitution
but what is religion
so many of us think freedom of religion
what that pertains to is being able to
go
to wherever it is you want to worship
whether it's a mosque or a temple or a
church
that freedom of religion to participate
in your religious practices
but what is religion
it's a set of beliefs
right
some people might say it's ideology
so i for instance
believe very strongly that there is one
god
the creator of heaven and earth
i don't go to church
but i have a religious practice in my
life
and i have beliefs that are associated
with that
other people believe there are many gods
other people believe that god is nature
and those beliefs will lead us to
different practices
it might be specific foods that we eat
or don't eat because it's part of our
religious beliefs it might be the way
that we dress it might be different
customs it might be the way we operate
and function in our daily lives
but it's based on those beliefs
so we're allowed to have and our beliefs
those religious freedoms to believe are
protected in these documents
they were provided for specifically
so if we look at
article 2 in the new hampshire
constitution in the bill of rights all
men have certain natural
essential
and inherent rights
natural
inherent
that means from god
it's not given to us by government right
it's from god
rights among which are the enjoying and
defending and i know you all know this
but we can't hear this enough
defending life and liberty
i'll skip through a little bit
seeking and obtaining happiness
so if we actually start to define these
words and what they mean
what is life
what is liberty
what is the ability to obtain
happiness the pursuit of happiness
and tie that in with the religious
freedoms and the protection
of our religious freedoms
article the next article 2b right of
privacy an individual's right to live
free from governmental intrusion
in private or personal information is
again natural
essential and inherent
some of these rights in article 4 it
states
are in their very nature unalienable
they cannot be taken away
this is the limit on government that our
founding fathers put in place
to keep us on course to not be in
continual debate about our beliefs
because we're going to have different
beliefs
every individual has a natural this is
article 5 a natural and unannual right
to worship god according to the dictates
of his own conscience
and reason and no subject shall be hurt
molested or restrained in his person
liberty liberty or estate for worshiping
god in the manner and season most
agreeable to the dictates of his own
conscience
so if it is in with my own conscience
that i do not
want to partake in a medical
intervention
that is a belief
that is an unan unalienable
belief
that cannot be taken from me
and no government can mandate
that i go against my conscience
it says it right here
i think the rest of these you all know
so i'm going to jump to some u.s code
so this is title 18
section 241
conspiracy against rights if two or more
persons conspire to injure oppress
threaten or intimidate any person in any
state territory commonwealth possession
or district in the free exercise
or enjoyment of any right or privilege
secured to him by the constitution
or the laws of the united states or
because of his having so exercised the
same
or if two or more persons go into skies
on the highway or on the premises of
another with intent to prevent or hinder
his free exercise or enjoyment of any
right or privilege so secured they shall
be fined under this title or imprisoned
not more than 10 years or both and if
death results from the acts committed
it can be sent there can be a sentence
of
death so
there's an oath that's taken
right to protect and uphold the
constitution
and that oath is taken
before god
so just like
there are consequences
for teenage children
who go off course or misbehave
or don't follow the rules of structure
there are consequences for those who
take an oath to uphold the constitution
of the united states or new hampshire
and who break
that oath
title 18 section 245
whoever whether or not acting under
color of law
by force or threat of force
willfully injures intimidates or
interferes with or attempts to injure
intimidate or interfere with
any person because he or he
is or has been or in order to intimidate
such person or any other person or any
class of persons from there's a whole
lot of them but i'm going to focus on c
which is applying for
or enjoying employment
or any prerequisite thereof
by any agency of the united states
in section two any person because of his
race color religion or national origin
applying for or enjoying employment or
any prerequisite thereof by any private
employer or any agency of any state or
subdivision thereof or joining or using
the services or advantage of any labor
organization hiring hall or employment
agency
and then there's lots more here but when
we get to the shell and shall not
so any
person whoever whoever whether or not
acting under the color of the law or not
shall be fined under this title or
imprisoned not more than one year
or both
and if bodily injury results from the
acts committed
in violation of this section
may be sentenced to death
so
i'm really just here to request
that you take your oath seriously
in upholding the new hampshire
constitution
and the constitution for the united
states of america
that we have freedoms that have been
granted to us
that cannot be taken away they are
unalienable
and those freedoms include our beliefs
our freedom of religion
and our founders put those in place
to help all of us
to help all of us stay on the course
of freedom and liberty
that was our main goal as a nation
to get away from tyranny
so those safeguards were put in place
for that reason so if we think we know
better if we think we can make up new
rules
and new standards
and create a new structure
let us not be
so arrogant
let us not be that teenager that
rebellious teenager and let us learn
from the past
let us learn from the wisdom and
experience of those founding fathers
and follow
suit
thank you
thank you are you willing to take
questions sure does the committee have
any questions for miss malloy
seeing none thank you very much
next up is louise spencer of concord
hi thank you for taking my comments
today
my name is louise spencer i'm from
concord new hampshire
and i was here at the monday hearing
i was asked
to provide some
information to louise can you step up to
them you're gonna need to talk a little
louder with your mask on or take it off
while you speak one of the two
um
i was asked to provide some information
uh to specifically representative leon
so i wrote a letter and follow-up to
that request
and i would like to read that for the
record
today
so
i write and follow up to your request at
today's public hearing that i forward
high quality medical studies that would
show i was correct in stating that there
was misinformation being presented at
today's hearing and elsewhere
and in support of my position
that elected officials must do a better
job on countering such misinformation
i am happy to provide you with
additional materials however given that
there was so much in-person testimony
with so much misinformation included i
respectfully request that you let me
know what specific points you would like
me to address
would it be the claim that covid
vaccines
that those
that the cova vaccine is a shot of aids
that those receiving the covid vaccine
are pricked with cancer-causing
substances that covet is not dangerous
that kovid does not kill anyone
that the vaccine does not protect
against variants that the kovid is not
that kovit is not a pandemic
there was other misinformation presented
but these seem some of the more prima
facie false claims
i apologize i had to leave early last
hearing so i might have missed others
it would have been helpful if you had
asked some of the people who spoke
against vaccines the same question you
asked me
and i would be interested in seeing
what high quality medical data they have
to support the claims listed above that
are clearly false
i appreciate that the covenanting virus
is a novel virus
and that the vaccine developed in
response the vaccines developed in
response are new
although they are indeed based on years
of research
i also recognize that there are many
issues upon which there is not yet broad
consensus within the medical and
scientific communities the role of
natural immunity being one such instance
where i think some of our elected
leaders do a disservice
is when they support or refuse to
confront
the sort of obvious disinformation
that sadly was too often on display
this failure undermines our ability to
have real conversations
and policy discussions that can help
lead to compromise and best practices
that benefit all of us
i again implore your committee
to adopt an affirmative statement
recognizing the critically important
role that vaccines have had
and continue to have in advancing and
maintaining good
public health
and promoting the adoption of
science-based immunization policies and
procedures
so that was my letter i also sent along
a follow-up that talked about the salk
and 7 vaccines
and the fact that both are still
variants of both are still in use today
with some having
value depending on the situation in
which they are used
i would also just like to
add that
upon hearing the last testimony
throughout the course of our nation
rights have always been balanced with
responsibilities
and that we have a court system that
helps us to navigate that difficult
process
rights often come into conflict with one
another
and there is no absolute right
guaranteed to anyone
in the constitution if there were
then the death penalty in every instance
would be
considered unconstitutional
but clearly
the right to life is not an absolute
right
so
at some point
we need to recognize
that difficult decisions have to be made
we had a founding father george
washington
who
required his troops to get vaccinated
did that violate violate violate other
rights
it certainly did
but a balance
had to be struck and a decision had to
be made
so with that i will conclude my
testimony for today
thank you any questions for ms spencer
erica representative
thank you um and if i may respond some
because that was a letter that was sent
to me
thank you for that information on the
sock and sabin i actually have had the
privilege of reading the typewritten
letter
from jonas salk when he was accepting
award at the white house because he
worked with saban to bring forth the
vaccines that actually were the ones
that did impact the world so thank you
for bringing light to that collaborative
decades-long process in order to perfect
the vaccines
when you speak to rights and
responsibilities
is there a different standard of rights
when you are offering a choice to
somebody or mandating them to take
to take a procedure
you know
i wish
that we had the same sort of
civic
engagement and sense of personal
responsibility
that would allow us
to really do a
rigorous and robust
public education campaign
that would help people to make
to understand that the vaccines are
generally safe
and that people would voluntarily take
these vaccines i really wish that was
the case
unfortunately that is greatly hampered
by
the sort of misinformation that is not
being confronted
that makes it difficult for people to
decide to voluntarily take that vaccine
and so if we were
taking away the misinformation and just
dealing with the facts
yes i can understand that there are some
people for religious or other purposes
that might decide not to
take the vaccine
but if 80 or 90 percent of the
population
were through good education efforts with
correct information
vaccinated that would be much less of a
problem we've seen that already with
vaccine programs about measles rubella
where the government puts out a campaign
with the help of public health officials
and the public responds in a generally
positive way
we've seen when
people
in certain communities have withdrawn
their support of vaccines we've seen
measles for example we've seen many
outbreaks small localized
um
not sure you would call it an epidemic
in that instance because it's local but
with a broad outbreak
so
um
you know i think we can get all riled up
about the mandates but i think there's
so much we could do
before
mandate before we even need to talk
about mandates
and i wish that our public leaders would
stand up
and start confronting this information
and help people get the real facts about
this vaccine
and my last follow-up is do you know the
difference between an observational
study
especially a retrospective observational
study and a prospective randomized
controlled trial
and the difference in clinical evidence
for them you know that's not my
responsibility here to know that you
have a state epidemiologist you have a
department of health
you can get that information there i'm
speaking as a public citizen as a
citizen here with my concerns i think
there's a role for lay information we
can call a spade
a state
you cannot look at
the claim
that the vaccine injects aids
and say that that is based on any
scientific data
and that should be confronted
and we should look to our leaders
to confront that information
so i don't need to be caught up in
requests for medical data
you have plenty of resources at your
disposal for that so thank you thank you
and the cdc guidelines are based upon
observational studies um and also the
other information is not trying to force
a choice so thank you so much for your
testimony thank you
ms spencer
one more one more question sorry
so i'm sure you can hear my frustration
because
i will admit i am highly frustrated by
what i saw on monday and what i'm seeing
here
and what i see go on
beyond these rooms so i am frustrated
so i guess my question is is to your
point of
conversation intelligent conversation
and i'm going to say non-emotional
conversation right because that's the
hardest part we have is right is when we
talk trying to have these conversations
for lack of a phrase in the abstract and
not in the in the emotional phase
so i guess my question is you know when
you're trying to have these
conversations do you agree it's
important to have the right data
yes right so
i i think that one of the things we we
talk about but we talk about vaccination
rates right we know that new hampshire
at least our new hampshire dashboards
wrong we know that the commissioners
come out and said that so they're
reporting roughly about eight hundred
thousand eight hundred thousand uh
citizens of native the 1.3 million in
our state have been vaccinated the cdc
reports over a million
right so we're approaching 80 percent
well beyond that
um the of of vaccinated people with
vaccinations i'm not let me finish in
new hampshire in new hampshire so we're
over a million citizens have had at
least one shot or a vaccine or
vaccinated according to the same metric
that the state's using on their website
which is 800 000.
so i guess my question is i guess my
point is is that
you agree we have to have honest
conversations right and we talk about
data when you're approaching over a
million people in new hampshire being
vaccinated then forcing upon the
remaining three hundred thousand
um
a vaccine they've chosen not to get for
whatever reason i don't know what those
reasons are i can't come up with 300 000
reasons why people may choose not to get
the vaccine but i guess my point is
don't you think we're just arguing over
the for the sake of arguing at this
point no not at all and i again i'm not
here primarily
to talk about the mandates
because i think
again there's a lot that we could do
shy of mandates i think in instances
mandates are necessary
what i'm really here to do
is to encourage your committee
to make a very strong and robust
statement that vaccines are
a critical part of our state health
policy public health policy that they
have
historically and currently
been critically important to the health
and well-being of our communities
and that
we need to
base our policies on good science and
data
so i agree that data is important i also
agree that there are places that we
don't have clear
data and i would love to have those
sorts of conversations but when those
conversations get obscured
by things that are clearly
clearly not true
then we can't really then that's when
the emotion starts going and we can't
then really sit down and make
compromises i have a niece whose
political views i do not share
and who is
she homeschools her children she is very
careful about what she
how she chooses you know their diet
she
is very conservative about
additives
and
various other things that go into their
body her children are vaccinated but she
has chosen not
to
vaccinate her children with covet
however
she also wears a mask and has her
children wear masks when they go out to
in public
she observes social distancing
she's respectful when someone else
expresses concern about the fact that
she's not vaccinated and makes a request
of them a simple
request and i really respect her and i
respect her opinion about that and i
understand that she has a different view
than i do about it i also understand
that there are religious exemptions
you know our constitution has a
conscientious objector clause in it
uh that is not always that's not
universally granted
so you know if you want to claim as a
quaker you know i'm familiar with people
seeking religious exemptions for things
like conscientious objection
but that's not you have to go and you do
actually have to present your religious
beliefs they don't have to be part of a
church they don't have to be something
that someone else determines
but you are required to show that it's a
sincerely held belief
so it's not
you know unprecedented for people to
have to actually um
say you know what
where their religious
concerns come from
so i just think that when we
you know
that there's a lot of room here
for us actually to have
conversation
what happens is we get into our camps
where we can't come together and
actually talk about the things that are
undecided that we don't have good data
on that people have questions about i
would love us to find that space and i
think one of the ways to find that space
is when we discard the clearly
incorrect information
and we begin with things that we can
start to verify and that we can start to
um
you know
put the science behind and i have no
problem standing here and saying that i
believe believe firmly in science and
science is an uncertain thing it doesn't
purport
to know everything in fact the opposite
science is about inquiry
and we need to be doing more inquiry
here
and then but we do at some point need to
look at the data that we get and make
some decisions based on that
thank you
any further questions
thank you very much thank you
next up is alexandra
manela
okay good morning i'm alexandra mannella
and i'm not going to state any
scientific studies
or
statistics
because i don't think those things
matter in this case
i don't need those things to know that
my civil rights are being violated
and i don't need those things
none of those things matter they don't
justify
mandates in this case so i'm not going
to go there i'm not going to talk about
statistics
or science that's not what matters right
now
i'm going to briefly comment on hb 220.
i think it's a good start
but there's a couple of things i would
change
so it states in paragraph one
every person has the natural essential
and inherent right to bodily integrity
free from any threat or compulsion by
government to accept an immunization
and i would add here a medical procedure
right because i i added this in because
i'm not really sure how far this
hysteria can go
it starts with immunizations and
vaccines
but who knows where this will lead
us i continue accordingly no person may
be compelled to receive
accordingly no person may be compelled
to receive an immunization
it originally said for covet 19 but i
would cross that out
and again add a medical procedure in
order to secure receive
or access any public facility any public
benefit or any public service from the
state of new hampshire or any political
subdivision thereof including but not
limited to counties cities towns
precincts water districts school
districts school administrative units or
quasi-public entities and the last
sentence i would add here
this shall apply to all private entities
seeking to do business or that are
currently doing business in the state of
new hampshire
now i am not up here advocating
for more laws
right i'm not happy that we need 32
bills
to try to protect our inherent rights
that's insane to me
i'm not advocating for more government
intervention or for socialism as our
government as our governor would call it
but right now we're in the middle of a
massive assault on our civil rights
under the guise of public health and
safety
your constituents
are being threatened by their employers
for not injecting pharmaceuticals into
their bodies
they're being forced to submit
themselves to regular medical testing
and absurd mask wearing
rituals they're being harassed by their
hr departments to disclose their
religious beliefs
right none of this is acceptable
and sadly we're starting to get
accustomed to this as a society
so i ask you do you really think that
coercing people into taking drugs and
treating
human beings like their farm animals
advances humanity in any meaningful way
this is barbaric
healthy people as if they're sick and
forcing them to consume drugs is
barbaric
and it's our duty and your duty
to put an end to this
and to put an end to the stranglehold
that big pharma has in this country
the science is nowhere near settled
on vaccines and it never ever will be
we shouldn't have to beg for exemptions
for our jobs we shouldn't have to be
justifying our religious beliefs to our
employers
right we don't want exemptions we just
want the mandates dropped
so again i don't want any more laws on
the books but we're sort of running out
of options here to resolve this thing
right now we're looking to our elected
leaders to defend our civil rights like
we pay them our taxes to do
but over the past two years
they've failed us in many ways
and again i say we're running out of
options
to live peaceable and quiet lives here
this is not the last pandemic that we're
going to go through
but i want you all to know that there is
no emergency in this world
even if half of the planet was dropping
dead from a pandemic
that justifies the suspension of our
natural
inherent
rights
and our individual liberties
it is not the role of our elected
officials to enslave us for our own good
we do not pay you to do this
and i'll end it here god is watching
what we do here
i pray for you all to turn to him
for your guidance on these matters and
your decision making
and thank you for the time
thank you alexander appreciate your
testimonies and we have a question for
alexandria
seeing none thank you very much
next up is diane lachance
good morning can you hear me with the
mask on
uh yeah if we have a problem i'll let
you know but just make sure you're up
close and you're speaking loud okay i
would prefer to wear the mask i am uh my
name is diane lachance i'm from kentucky
new hampshire
um i prefer to wear the mask because i'm
not vaccinated and i
i have to say i'm being denied the
vaccine because i'm being denied
important information about my medical
health in order to make the appropriate
decision for myself
and
i i come here a little bit unprepared
because i've been spending countless
hours watching the fda hearings from
start to finish and your meeting and
realized that my opportunity to speak
was
coming to a close and i better come down
and just speak from my heart and hope
that
my emotions don't overtake me but
i agree
with the people who speak about wanting
data i think it's very important and
misinformation
today
makes us all spend countless hours
looking for the truth
um
i find it very hard to talk to people
about what's going on with the fda and
the cdc and the formulation of this
vaccine because
people don't even feel like they are
smart enough to watch those hearings and
i will tell you that most of the
scientists who speak i don't know what
they're talking about but i have to say
they're very intelligent people and they
make very intelligent conclusions that
the layperson can understand i have a
brother as a nuclear engineer if i ask
him a question about the nuclear
industry
he knows how to talk to people who don't
understand it
so i would encourage people to watch
those hearings because if you do i think
you might come up to the same conclusion
that i am is that
um
there's still a lot of data that we
don't have
they claim that working at the speed of
science
i worked for a pharmaceutical research
and manufacturing company for 18 years
i know very well the speed of science it
is not fast
this is going much too fast
if
people who are concerned about us
getting the right data
um want to champion something um how
about let's talk about the vares reports
let's have a really honest discussion
about what that data
means
i'm feeling a little
i don't know what the right word is um
still trying to sort out
what i heard
at the
fda approval meeting for the five to 11
year olds and that was a i believe and
again i don't i've been spending a lot
of time and i only have so much time and
i will say i wish you'd have one more
public meeting next week and i would
promise to come with a prepared script
and much more thorough
testimony
because
in a little bit of time i had to look
into
the v-safe app that was rolled out with
the 5-11
approval
from what i can see
parents can enroll their children let
them know they have that vaccine or any
vaccine that they have ever had
and they will get notifications when
vaccines are due and parents can also
log in that they've had an adverse
reaction their child
and there's already been some talk
that parents are going to believe that
they have reported an adverse event this
app and it clearly states it on the
website
is not theirs
you have to also go to theirs
the speed at which we all
operate and use apps and whatever i
think is another danger because i don't
think parents understand that if their
child has a severe reaction i'm sure the
first thing they're going to do is go to
that app because the first thing they
want is medical attention for their
child
but how many are going to assume
that that data
is being looked at for the study
how long will it take for us to get that
data
to understand what is happening with the
five to 11 year olds if it's not going
into theirs or there's a
misunderstanding against we're going to
have some more backlogged data i see it
as a double accounting system which
doesn't belong anywhere
um and i think this committee i would
implore you to look at that
the v
safe program is so new that wikipedia
doesn't even have a article about it yet
so i
we're going to all be
going on facebook and hearing this
information like people have warned
against and real information but we're
not going to know what it is so
the new information i bring to you is
the v safe
app and how that is
going to help our hurt
this conversation and the ability for us
all to make the right decision for
ourselves
i just want to check real quick some
notes i made
i don't believe that the majority
opinion
is what our constitution
intended to be the dictator of what we
do
um
and
with that i'm just going to say you know
if that's how some people think
saint anselm's public policy did a
recent poll and it says that most people
although they
agree with the vaccine
don't agree with the mandate
i'm just throwing that out to the people
who believe that majority opinion is
what should determine our decisions
i'm going to stop there because i am not
real prepared and i don't want to just
ramble on um i'm just going to again
repeat
please check the v safe everyone take a
look at it i'd like to hear what people
have to say about it
i believe it's a double data
collection i think we're not going to
get information as quickly as we need
important information so i thank you
very much
sorry thank you any questions
thank you very much i do want to correct
something i said i said earlier that
there were roughly seven thousand
uh reported covert deaths that were
related to and i quote
intentional unintentional injury or
poisonings and that number is really
fifteen thousand one hundred not seven
thousand
all right next up is
allison dyer
hi
i'm allison dyer i'm from national new
hampshire
thank you for giving us the opportunity
to speak today
i understand that this committee is
reviewing a vast array of bills related
to immunizations
i am cautiously hopeful that your
reasons for wanting our input in these
sessions is because you do in fact
plan to utilize it as we are asking in
your roles as elected officials
i'm one of your new hampshire residents
that has been begging and pleading for
you to stand up for the live free or die
state
i've lived here in new hampshire all my
life i work here i was married here i
gave birth to my daughter here
and i love my life here because i love
what new hampshire had to offer and what
new hampshire has afforded to myself and
my family
i'm also the daughter of a nurse
a nurse whose career has spanned 47
years who cannot be here today to speak
but faces the same fate as i and so many
here today
my mother a nurse of 47 years a woman
who has dedicated her life to caring for
others will lose her job in five days
due to the vaccine mandate
a nurse who contracted kovid while
working through the pandemic but never
missed a beat
now despite her antibodies still showing
nine months later
will have her career ended in a way that
couldn't be more degrading giving her 47
years of devoted service and faithful
service to the care of others
her provider would not sign off on her
medical exemption
despite the adverse and very scary
vaccination and immunization history
that she has
she has submitted a religious exemption
based on her sincerely held beliefs but
to date we have no response and based on
what so many others in the health care
field have been communicating these
exemptions are all being denied
so our employers and this administration
has been given license to be judge jury
and executioner of our faith as well as
our
bodies i myself have worked in the
healthcare field for 15 years
i lost my job at dartmouth-hitchcock
on october the 8th
i was there for 14 years
and ate as a remote only employee
doing prior authorizations i like my
mother had coveted too i have antibodies
a full 10 months later
my medical exemption was denied
despite my documented history of severe
allergic reactions
despite a letter from my primary care
stating i should not get this vaccine
despite my antibody test and despite my
plea of abject fear that as a mother of
a young child with my history of very
visceral
and horrific reactions to immunizations
that i was afraid to die
darth hitchcock sent me my denial for
the covid vaccine
my approval for the flu vaccine
exemption as i have had for 10 years
and my termination paperwork
14 years gone
and the kicker is three days after i was
terminated for not complying with the
vaccination because my natural immunity
meant nothing despite what history has
always told us about prior infections
and antibodies
the red cross called me to ask me if i
would donate more blood because i'm a
universal donor with covet antibodies
my natural immunity was good enough to
donate blood to help persons recover
from covid but not good enough to keep
my job
i face the same at my current employer
our date is 11 15 i will lose my health
insurance and the ability to care for my
daughter
i have again applied for exemptions but
to date have received no response
despite my efforts to follow up
if it goes anything like it did at
dartmouth i will essentially be homeless
on monday along with my mother
dr strang pointed earlier in this week
to informed consent cannot be defined in
this situation
this is not patient centered
these mandates and the inaction of our
elected officials to clarify what they
mean for new hampshire has led to chaos
employers are so fearful to not be able
to report a business-wide 99 vaccination
rate that they're willing to terminate
healthcare workers who for their entire
careers pandemic aside
have been unwavering in their care of
all of us
when have we had press announcements of
business flu vaccination rates i tried
to look i couldn't find any major
announcements about the compliance of
flu from any institutions
back in 2010 when they began
mandating the flu vaccine in the health
care setting the vaccine had been out
and fda approved since 2007
and the nasal flu since 2003
so for the vaccine three whole years of
data people had to review before making
the decision to be vaccinated
it's november 10 2021 the covid vaccine
under emergency use has been available
to the general public for less than one
full year still
and still the fda approved one only came
in august so less than three months why
was it okay for the flu vaccine to allow
people to take the time to review the
data and decide but now we're being
forced to choose between taking care of
our families
our careers for less than a year's worth
of real-time data
why does new hampshire's own laws allow
for natural immunity as an exemption to
vaccination but not for this one
is it because we used to use history and
historical data prior to covid
and while the covet 19 is a newer virus
it would seem that everything that came
before in history from mass studies to
natural immunity was just thrown out the
proverbial window
and despite the fda advisory committee
stating quote we're never going to learn
about how safe this vaccine is unless we
start giving it
one of our very own new hampshire
representatives put in an lsr to require
the covid vaccine in order to attend
public school
free fair and appropriate education but
only if you vaccinate your child and
hope it's safe
the nih is quietly studying the effects
of this vaccine on women's menstrual
cycles on august 30th on the nih website
listed in their items of interest
section
they had been given a grant for 1.67
million dollars
to study the correlation of the covid
vaccine to changes in women's menstrual
cycles
heavier than usual bleeding and other
changes
but you want me as a mother and a woman
to give this to my seven-year-old
daughter
in a society to attend school knowing i
could potentially be altering her
ovaries or causing permanent damaging
hormonal changes to her body at seven
years old
for a virus that she has a 99.9 chance
of recovery from
also shouldn't this study the nih is
doing be enough for women in the
workforce to be medically exempt from
the vaccine at this time
at least until the study is completed
and vetted
but no
i along with my mother will lose my
full-time job in five days
if some of this legislation comes to
pass this next session families will
also be forced to make a decision to
vaccinate their children or leave the
public school system
for anyone thinking of that by the way
check out education freedom accounts
thank you glenn cordelli and
commissioner edelblue
lastly anyone who has critical thinking
brain or individual thought could see
the writing on the wall for all of this
when they said two weeks to slow the
spread
that we would be on the fast track to
losing liberty to life
and live as we choose
so here we are almost two years later
so with this committee and the 32 bills
looking to come through this house
during this session i'm here today to
ask that you return what is rightfully
ours as citizens of america and to
restore new hampshire to the live free
or die state that we all knew once and
loved
thank you very much alison there's any
questions for allison
not seeing anything thank you allison
stephen robinson
good morning can you hear me
just step up to the mic and speak nice
and loud
uh i heard that you had some issues with
emails i sent on monday uh so i want to
read my email i sent as long as well as
a um something i wrote this morning as
well you can hear me right you can
go ahead and read your email
all right
good morning my constituents
we the people of the liver-free and dice
of new hampshire i wanted to be heard
that i am all against mandates that
pertain to immunizations as before us
today and being talked about at this
meeting the choice is the personal one
for each of us and the freedom of choice
freedom of truth that goes in our bodies
this has to stop
we have a constitution in place in the
law of the land and for every human
being in it
must be upheld
you all took an oath when elected to
fulfill your oath
with a 99.8 recovery rate against this
virus flu
our own immune system is the best
defense against this man-made virus
viruses have been around since the dawn
of time
and will always be
this train of destruction has to stop
against the american people in the
theory the thievery that comes with it
in the form of grants and big farmer
it must be shut down once and for good
for the sake of mankind
i personally have experienced three
direct deaths
due to this vaccine
most recently i've uncovered two weeks
ago okay of heart failure
okay two neighbors two months ago of
heart failure after getting fully
vaccinated everybody in this room has
been exposed to covet at some level
your own astro immune is the immune
system is gonna help you fight this not
a man-made genocide jab
personally
as i was driving in this morning on 93 i
saw a road sign it says 99 deaths too
many
how many are on the verge report
way too many
all right that being said
put a stop to the mandates
this goes to my notes i wrote this
morning
as an informed concerned educated
citizen of the united after new
hampshire the live free of dicey and a
proudest citizen of the united states of
america
and as a husband father and friend
and the most important title i carry is
to do a little innocent child that calls
me papa my granddaughter okay
that's why i'm here
fighting for her rights and the rights
of these children that these mandates
are going against these kids five to
five year old that's ridiculous totally
absurd
as you all heard testimony on monday
with clear and concise facts from
doctors lawyers emts mothers fathers and
parents to be along with grandparents
and people who love their freedom and
what was granted to them in the
constitution in the bill of rights page
four articles articles one two and two b
i can read them if you want but already
no sense repeating ourselves
that being with that being said
i as i walk in this morning i was here
at 7 30 quarter of eight i happened to
notice that the marines were celebrating
their birthday
246 years i'm going to read until i
wrote about
that uh as we celebrate the birthday of
the united states of america
american marine corps established in
1775 240 years 46 years of bravery and
honor to defend the constitution
i'm sorry i left my place for a second
and the citizens of the usa
those brave men and women who gave some
and gave all for freedom and the
american way of life with that being
said it makes me very angry along with
many others that we are here today
discussing infringes on our freedoms at
many levels
i'm fortunate to stand here today taking
time off work as others cannot there are
many more i guarantee a hundred percent
that would love to be here and fill this
chamber beyond capacity this whole
concern
coercion collusion between big farmer
and government and the cabal and the
elite has to stop not today not
yesterday
not last month it should never happen
you are all breaking the laws of the
land
okay
as we all see here every day the effects
of the so-called vaccine is called the
genocide mrna jab and it makes you
non-human anymore along with the 5g who
knows what that's going to do to people
okay
you recall killing killing innocent
people for the wealth and power and
control
dr fauci has been caught in so many lies
it's beyond me why he's still in a
position
he isn't it's crimes against humanity
remember the nuremberg trials history
will repeat itself
okay i like to end on that note
any newscast
or webpage that labels me as an
anti-vaxxer or
other defaming name you will have legal
action taken against you
i want to be known
not as a anti-vascular but as a pure
blood thank you
thank you mr robinson any any questions
from the committee
seeing none thank you very much
derek arnold
good morning
board committee and good morning we are
the people
i lived
my 50 years
my kids
have not yet
my grandbabies have not yet
they deserve the opportunity
we all have had
we know
that any structure
needs has an architect
it needs to be built
on solid ground
we call new hampshire the granite state
our constitution of 1776
the architects our forefathers
the most bold line on that is we the
people
we the people
pay all of your salaries
anybody that takes an oath
to protect
all
humanity there's a monument
out front here
that states it
i expect
the hearts
of the people
that are making these decisions
to do the right things
from your heart
i didn't come here with a planned speech
i am not a public speaker
i travel state to state
seeking truth
speaking truth i've been to the border
wall i've been to the white house
i travel from florida to the texas
from florida to maine
my both my grandfathers were war heroes
george arnold was u.s navy
he was he swam back on the uss
independence
saving lives
he was on the uss hornet
he was dead
when i was a year old
by big pharma
wrong heart medication
so
when are we gonna
bring the facts
transparency and truth because fake news
does not do that
so i
am in a position where i need to be
front line boots on the ground seeking
the truth for we the people for my kids
and my grandbabies
plain and simple
and all these people here and everybody
that might watch this and everybody in
every country
every county every state every town
we have
our free will
and our free choice
that was given to us in 1776
however
the act of 1871
started
to take that from us
and if you look on the back of your
dollar bill at the pyramid with the
all-seeing eye
that scares us in the face all our life
the fake fiat currency that has no gold
back has no backing whatsoever
okay all this money that big farmer is
putting in their pockets
all our selected officials not fairly
elected officials
taking the seats to serve we the people
are taking bribes
no more
fooling we the people
we the people
are taking
our solid foundation
we are the architects
of what
we put in our bodies
i don't believe in putting experimental
drugs in my body and i don't believe
that anybody should be forced on that i
want to read
the definition
of a vaccine
and then i'm going to break down
one
specific
word
in this
so derek here you're
i'll give you an extra a couple minutes
but we're approaching 10 minutes now and
so if we could
kind of tighten it up a little bit so
let's do this
let's go to the mass first let's cover
that first
because masks
are proven
they do not stop viruses the package in
the hospital with the blue mask
states on the back therefore emergency
only they do not stop viruses if you
were to find
one type of mass that is a hundred
percent proof
stopping a virus
then each and every one of us would have
to wear
that particular mask
we don't go make our own mask with
fabric
and say that is stopping a virus
that is stopping your voice
we experienced over there with a mask on
your voice that your voice can't be
heard clearly
so that's the mask
situation
now this experimental
drug that has truly not been fda
approved only emergency only so let's
put the facts out let's be transparent
about things
because that's what the world needs
that's what we the people need we need
transparency through out
not when you choose to be transparent
i don't plan speeches i don't write them
i speak from my heart
so
how are we forcing an experimental drug
that's
biological
which is stated
in the definition of a vaccine let's
break that word down bio
logical
bio
logical well
our 1776 we had common law the act of
1871 put us into maritime law
well how about we go into common
sense law with logic
awareness and wisdom
do your due diligence do your research
because i do hours and hours and hours
of it i travel
many many states
on my time in my dine i don't get paid
to do what i do
i don't have children in schools but i
go to the school board meetings
why because all life matters
all humanity matters
the tree of life
the birds
all created life
not
man
you
factured
or manipulated
or man dates
how about we keep our god given rights
and i'm going to stop there because i
guess my 10 minutes is up and i
appreciate the time you have given me
and i appreciate all these people that
stand beside me and they go out in these
streets into the hospitals and school
boards that stand aside me
for the same reason to save all humanity
thank you derek appreciate your
testimony any questions for derek
seeing none thank you very much sir
next up is josie and i apologize josie
i'm not going to try to butcher your
last name
hi uh good morning my name is josie
kumandala for the record i'm a resident
of bedford new hampshire and uh i'm just
gonna reel it back in i'm gonna keep it
really short
um
so i just wanna express my concern about
the wording of the amendment to
hb220 the language currently states that
no person may be compelled to receive an
immunization for covet 19 in order to
secure receive or access any public
facility
my question is what about a vaccine for
covid 20 covid 21.
the media is constantly reminding us and
warning us about variants and
they'll this will surely lead to more
boosters and new vaccines
and i'm also concerned that you know
based on
the warnings of the experts
that on a long enough timeline
nobody is going to be fully vaccinated
because the cdc and the who reserve the
right to update their definition of
fully vaccinated
so it's it's my wish to express my
concern that we need to take a hard line
now against any and all coerced medical
procedures uh covet 19 flu
anything we just we need to uphold the
right of bodily autonomy my body my
choice
that needs to be inscribed as the law of
the land
and that's got to be fundamental
this human right also um in
regards to this bill i don't think this
bill goes far enough um in protecting
the most vulnerable of society i.e the
children the elderly the incarcerated
the mentally ill
human beings uh are sacred they have
inaudible lights endowed by their
creator
uh as for me personally i have no king
but jesus
um and i think that this bill is a good
start but in many ways does not go far
enough in upholding our fundamental
inalienable human rights
thank you
questions
so josie i'll just give you a couple
comments
i was the author of hb220 and senator
bradley
was amended some of that bill
and there are several bills that are
currently pending um including one to
repeal it all together
and so just know there there are we are
looking at that bill in the upcoming
session to see how it can be modified
excellent thank you
[Applause]
kate smith
thanks for letting me speak
if you just speak step up so we can hear
you better my name is catherine smith
i'm 56 year old resident of chichester
i've lived in new hampshire since 2000.
during this time i've worked in health
care i earned my associates degree at
nhti
and then my bsn at snhu
i stand here before you as an educated
medical person who has been vaccinated
over thirty times
i am also a parent who has an
eighteen-year-old son and he's been
vaccinated every
time they require it up until this year
so please when i speak before you today
do not think for one minute to label me
as an anti-vaxxer misinformed or a
conspiracy theorist
because i have none of those attributes
thirty years ago the idea of global
tyranny under the premise of a global
economic system was revealed to me by an
author named gary carr
he wrote a book entitled enroute to
global occupation
and in an attempt to it was his attempt
to warn the world about this plan that
was in process
and since that time i've witnessed this
plan unfold
hence when the president of the united
states declared the country was going to
be locked down along with the rest of
the world
due to a novel virus i felt mentally and
spiritually prepared for what was
unfolding
as we stand here today and we deliberate
the policy of medical interventions i
politely ask you to please just stop all
the rhetoric we need to start calling
out this pandemic for what it is
our terrorist attack on the global
population
using a bioweapon created with tax
funded
money by our scientists who we hire
to protect us
this attack has been followed by an
incessant propaganda campaign of
fear-mongering and psychological warfare
to move this people towards vaccination
status
and that's what we stand here today
to vaccinate or not to vaccinate
this is also an attempt to move the
united states population from exercising
their constitutional freedoms as
lawmakers continually abuse their
position to create new restrictions on
our rights and liberties
selling us the idea that the needs of
the many outweigh the needs of the few
is intended not for our safety are out
of concern for our health and well-being
but it is a move to uh it is rather to
move our society into corporate fascism
which in turn permits our politicians to
move forward with their build back
better campaign which is right out of
the united nations language
we know what you're doing
we know all the funding that follows
build back better we
it's the green new deal
and they're using all the covert relief
funding to put in this infrastructure
the real issue any of us should be
talking about is the ensuing coveted
passport
which is the capstone of this virus
lockdown mass squaring social distancing
contact tracing asymptomatic spread
nasal swab and vaccine
baloney
our this operation has been distracting
the american people for 22 months
we know the covet passport is about a
digital identity created on the
blockchain system
it exists in china
they're pushing it in israel they're
pushing in other states countries around
the world they're implementing it in new
york they're pushing in orange county it
has many names the wellness passport
health passport excelsior app an
application you're telling us to put in
well i'm here to tell you that the men
and women of new hampshire have played
this pandemic game politely for far too
long
every patriot i have met over the last
22 months would rather stand and resist
this technocratic tyranny than succumb
under the guise of fear and safety and
most would rather die than to come to
this type of total surveillance and loss
of self-autonomy
now is the time for you
to stop fooling yourselves and insulting
your constituents
with this continual barrage against our
rights as free men and women living on
the land of this wonderful continent
we know our freedoms and our liberties
and they're endowed by our creator we
know who we fight and we know what we
fight for
so i have to turn the focus not on
vaccines but on your role at this time
in history
it's time for the elected body to come
together and to make your stand
with your fellow countrymen and women
it is this moment in history that you
will never get back
it is time for you as representatives of
the people of new hampshire to stand
with the people for freedom to resist
this tyranny and to be a beacon of light
a glimmer of hope for the rest of the
country
for when one stands and we another
stands and then another and then we can
all stand together united as people to
say no our children is are not for sale
for we are not divided we stand united
and we will fight
we know our rights and we understand our
common law
we are coming for our sheriffs our
policy makers our elected officials our
teachers and anyone else who stands with
the globalist and attempt to take away
our freedom
we will hold you accountable
and when this war is won
we will hold you accountable because we
will win this war we will not succumb
and it is your job
to know the pulse of your people
and i have been out there for 10 11 12
months talking to people on the streets
and people know what's happening they're
not stupid
we don't
want to play this vaccine game because
we know the end game is a vaccine
passport
and we know where that's taking us and
we know what is coming and we will not
take it
thank you
thank you very much kate
i just want to take a moment apparently
we have a fourth grade class that's come
to visit us up in the gallery so i want
to thank you guys for coming
and i hope you enjoy your tour of the
state house which school we got up there
today
i'm sorry can someone repeat what they
said i can't hear
rye elementary school well thank you
guys for coming i hope you enjoy the
state house and enjoy your day today
all right next up we have
catherine
mendola i believe it is
let's set that aside
next we'll have uh virgin genus fernand
for now i can't say the name
v-i-r-g-i-n-i-c-e it looks like
nope
okay hold off on that one
next up we have
oh i'm sorry go ahead mim i didn't see
you stand up
did you say your name for the record so
i can virginia thank you
go ahead ma'am
so i am completely out of my comfort
zone here i just need to say that
i'm a grandmother
and i've lived in new hampshire since
1970.
i have
eight grandchildren one
great-grandchildren
child
and i'm here on their behalf
most of the people that have spoken this
morning i completely agree with
i believe that we are on a path right
now
that at this moment in time
we have the opportunity
maybe the last one
to reverse the direction
that seems to be overwhelming us right
now
i have a grandson who is a very gifted
and talented physical therapist
who has had to choose
to either get
this is
this morning printed from the virus
we asked for documentation
site
he had to choose between taking all of
these risks into his body and into his
life
or
lose his ability to
support his family
i believe he's wisely chosen
to not do this to himself
out of work
as things stand right now he will not be
able to return
to what he's gifted and talented for
which was the care
of our senior population in their home
i have another friend here in new
hampshire who works from
home
for a company
that is requiring everyone to be
universally
vaccinated with all of these
ramifications
or lose his job in two weeks
none of this makes sense
none of us serves the purpose
i am an old lady
i need
medical
facilities
that i can go to when my body breaks
down
i sleep at night because i have people
out there who protect me and have always
protected me and my family
the fire the police
communities that have taken care of each
other
in the face of whatever has come our way
if this is not stopped now
we the people will not be protected
we will not have life-sustaining
services that we rely on
our children
will be damaged by this give them the
vaccine
and then we'll see what happens
what
does that mean
what does that mean
that all of our children can be just
random
test subjects
i beg you for the benefit of my family
to stand at this pivotal time in history
because you may never be given this
chance to do it again if you don't do it
now for us
please
obey your oath of office i was there
october 13th and i saw what it looks
like when people do not follow their
oath of office their order to not follow
their low oath of office please don't be
a part of that
please thank you
thank you virginia any questions for
virginia
saying none thank
you so a card i can't read but the
gentleman's from hillsborough i
don't know what is for label
labrie limbri
is that
yeah that's cory cory maybe
labrie
could you say your name so i can get it
right corey lavoy from hillsborough
deering county rats
thank you for to be assembled and the
committee for giving this time to speak
um by now you've heard all the data
that's held in contention by
contemporary media and
attempts to enforce consensus
on this topic
and
i could go into
well by not saying i'm going to go and
do a little bit mass mandates are an
interesting point here because that was
kind of the opening of the just speaking
to the mic and we're having a hard time
there you go
it's almost like the opening of a foot
in the door with the mass mandates was
this idea that it's completely false so
they don't protect you no they don't
protect you there's data that's gone out
explaining how they collect contaminants
in the membrane of the mask thereby
contributing to oral infection and lung
infections
now going from that
we have the whole thing kicked in the
door in the face saying the alternative
to mass is vaccination well
let's go to what the core issue that is
is human sovereignty and saying that
your body as it stands is inadequate
without some form of medical
intervention that is a policy that we've
had in this nation since birth subjected
to young males in the form of infant
angelic mutilation known as circumcision
sorry to say
now
we see that then being a
kind of underground kind of
gestalt in our society well that again
is saying that the body as it stands is
not adequate
as it is created and produced
we are or biological organisms we shed
skin cells we have hair drop out we have
you know boogers and snot and all that
kind of stuff we're a little grime
there's
a fear of that
written in the human paradigm that has a
sensical aspect but against it's
nonsense too and we get the nonsensical
side of it you get something that
becomes servile and very vindictive
because it's afraid of itself it's
afraid of human nature it does not want
people to be walking around breathing
freely because it's scared of what that
other person might not just breathe out
but what might come through the person's
energy and their breath when they speak
if we go to just want to go to
historical context on this i actually
find myself going back to the back
looking into the black plague that hit
europe
this was said to be a respiratory tract
infection in both cases
but in the case of
the after effects of the vaccine and the
strange phenomena that was called the
saint vista stance during that time
period people were having definite
neurological conditions and symptoms and
reactions to what was said to be covered
if you look at the symptoms of covid
they overlap
with co2 poisoning with oxygen
deprivation and neurological conditions
that would be bought eventually be
brought about by this vaccine
it is a daunting
endeavor to be able to look at this
unbiased and understand how deeply this
was planned out
but it's something that we have to face
and i come back again to the term
survival to be servile that
vindictiveness
it's that fear but also kind of perverse
need to bring everyone down to your
level to say that this person you know
threatens me by their
being more aware or being more empowered
in themselves and therefore i want to
take them down a pet because i don't
feel that in myself
that i believe is the core aspect of
this that we are facing as a nation and
something that's coming out
as we are inevitably obligated to
consider these factors and how
your fear
does not ultimately enable you or should
not enable you to dictate to other
people
how they live their lives how they
express themselves how they have free
enterprise
what you see as being wrong about them
without concretely examining or deciding
if it really is correct or not for the
body politic
these are all factors that were being
made to face yet again
in a kind of
very much a boiling over almost
of these factors that have been
simmering in our cultural gestalts and
our
existence
as
humanity
and now comes the time when we have to
decide
the path we're going to follow to
promote which is really helpful which
really helps and sustains human life
versus that servile aspect that will
comply with tyranny and say
basically you know as long as you're
as long as i have my standing i don't
care how far it makes other people fall
i don't care if other people get pulled
down by it because
because of being told again and again
that people are inadequate that we're
flawed
that that means that everyone else
has to be
you know in a state of duress of being
you know feeling comfortable that
it's
to try and explain for well i can't i
can't explain much further than that
really with what i'm trying to
articulate by those points
i'm sure if the committee and those here
speaking on behalf
of sovereignty
are you know seeing that too but you
know everyone
they're going can speak on it and bring
some clarity to it counts
thank you corey is there any questions
corey was it yes corey for any questions
for corey
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony today sir very much appreciate
it thank you
catherine mendola
i think i asked for her before
nope
we have three more speakers or
unless we find catherine and we have
four
paula john i think it is
so just give everyone an update while
she's coming up to the microphone the
goal is we have three speakers left
counting paula um we'll take a a brief
recess and we'll reconvene in a
different room um and the committee will
start doing some of its work on what the
report will look like
excuse me one second
all right go ahead paul i apologize
that's okay good morning
i'm members of the committee and thank
you for allowing me to come here again
today to speak
monday was in better shape than i am
today because i am a person with a
disability although i don't look like i
have a disability i do
and i'll tell you something i'm getting
sick and tired of being discriminated
against out there and even at my board
meetings because i am elected too
this thing with the mask has gone way
too far
way too far because if you have a
disability you can't breathe with it it
doesn't matter you're discriminated
against and on monday i said i will be
losing my job tomorrow because i cannot
wear a mask because i cannot breathe
with it
and it is really a shame what's going on
in this state
i didn't come prepare to write anything
because i came in very quickly because
my body does not allow me to walk move
fast that's at times and so today i'm
standing here in excruciating pain and
the thought of being vaccinated i think
would kill me because of my autoimmune
because of fibromyalgia oh that's right
people don't know that much about
fibromyalgia this is a very debilitating
disease it affects the nerves and the
muscles and i don't talk about it very
much because i try to go on with my life
as normal for 29 years from a severe
auto accident that i had
and i got up this morning's the first
time that i've gotten up and felt beaten
up by the board i sat on last night
going after me again because i cannot
wear masks trying to help people with a
disability to make
accessible access for them
and you know and i look at around here
and these children that i that were up
here that came in with masks
masks so
i did some a little bit of work here
thank god for these phones i guess i
hate it because they track you every
place you go
um you know and i'm looking at
some things here cdc
okay
who owns a cdc big farmer owns the cdc
so that's why they tell us what to do
that we have to take the vaccines make
no mistakes they do
um
i'm going through some cdc gets millions
of dollars annually from big pharma
of course
that's why they all want us to have the
vaccines
oh and fda who do they get their funding
from now fda's funding has increasingly
come from industries that it regulates
my mother used to say if fda approves it
don't take it they're going to kill you
she was absolutely right even with this
emergency youth authorization
and i said on monday i sat in this
chamber here my seat was 5-17
and i didn't realize that that was my
mother's birthday and she passed away in
march after i got sworn in but she gave
me the courage to sit here and he didn't
vote party lines i voted what i thought
was best for the state and my
constituents in nashua
because the people elected me like they
have done in nashua again
to do the best that i have to do to
protect them and the kids
but why i came flying up here again this
morning late
because i couldn't move this morning and
a friend of mine called me and i was
crying on the phone nobody ever sees me
crying because i have to be strong for
my constituents
i'm tired of getting beaten up everybody
who's sitting here is tired of getting
beaten up that we should have to come
here and beg our elected officials to do
what they have to do is right
then
we took i talked about in the
spring of last year the mass that the
parents in florida
that sent out to get tested
and you know what came back in those
masks
legionnaires disease from the bacteria
streptococcus wait a second that's
that's worse than the backs
than the vaccine in certain extents
well let me back up that's worse
than covert
because children don't get covert and if
they do it's very minimal
their survival rate is better than
anybody else but then again you know
let's talk about cuomo put elderly
patients who were sick in a nursing home
and killed them that was
the whole thing to kill off the elderly
so then
we have what else do we have in here
i hit my page
and i'm not going to be shut down and
speaking from what i'm going to say you
get pneumonia tuberculosis tuberculosis
is worse than covet
meningitis is worse than covet
and the list goes on and on and on
parasites fungi dangerous pathogens
cloth the paper masks they're coming
back with they're having carcinogens
in it
masks preliminary lab analysis found
toxic chemicals in these paper masks and
some masks these include known allergens
and carcinogens as well as control
substance mass intent to be used by the
general public are not deemed to be ppe
therefore they do not have to meet the
standards by mass sworn by doctors
eighty percent eighty-five percent of
all mass made worldwide come from china
china that's where the
covet came from china
and concerns have been raised over
substandard and manufacturing
supply chains
so we're putting these on our face and
even
the kids have said toxic because i
brought it to my meeting
so what i want to say here i guess maybe
in closing
i'm going to read a list here and i'm
not going to be stopped
uh are these as long as it's not getting
into personal attacks please go ahead
you know what it's not it's just a list
of it's not a personal attack this is
public it's just a list of all our state
senators who took money
from um fisa and i think it has to be
known that where
this is about policy and not about
people you know what i i'm allowed
you can't stop the public from doing
this because i think people need to know
because of the fact that we have to come
here this is my second time here
begging
begging for people for our rights in
this state and one of the senators is
sitting right there and i won't mention
the name
sixty four hundred dollars from fisa so
how does a senator sit on a committee
and how does anybody sit on these
committees sit and vote on policy for us
that we're fighting not to take the jab
not to have the masks on these kids when
they take money from these big farmers
am i correct everybody here
we the people
we the people so it is public record so
i'm going to start sharon carson 7 650
jeff bradley 6400 chuck moore 6 470
700 america
please
this is this is in the public record if
people want to look it up they can look
to the campaign finance system
it is
but we're not going for public attack
going for personal
sorry we're not going for the personal
it's not personal
but i'll tell you thank you very much
because now the people are starting to
see here who's taking the money
and why we the people
have to come here
and fight for our rights and these are
our forefathers who gave us our
god-living rights and given us our
rights to be here no citizen in this
state should have to fight live free or
die and if you want to take the money
don't run for election we don't want any
of you anymore
thank you ma'am
rosemary rosemary landry
i guess this is high enough for me
um my name is rosemary landry and i am
from america new hampshire
i am a mother a grandmother and a
registered nurse i am retired at the
present but i
nourished in medical surgical nursing
and pediatric nursing was
my heart and soul
so i am here to talk
about different
different avenues of the um
so-called um
gene therapy
which is its real name it's not a
vaccine they just put a vaccine name on
it to hide it so
we've never seen
this level of side effects for any
vaccine gene therapy injection without
the fda taken action
the rotovirus vaccine was canceled
was canceled for 15 cases of non-lethal
side effects and the swine flu vaccine
was canceled for 25 deaths
but now by the cdc's own data we are
seeing a 1200
12 000
increase in deaths
with these vaccines and they are
promoting this to our kids
children's ace receptors are not
prominent therefore they are not getting
covered
as much
pediatrician dr larry palowski
state ace receptors and children do not
connect well
now um with your permission
i forgot to say good morning to
everybody and thank you for listening
my i'm going want to read the adverse
reactions
the list they are numerous there's 23 of
them
number one is gillian boss syndrome
two is
acute disseminated encephalitis
myelitis transverse myelitis a lot of
the side effects have to do with the
spinal cord
encephalitis myelitis encephalomyolite
myelitis meningitis encephalitis and
meningitis convulsion seizures stroke
deaths
let's see here
where am i
okay um
all right
stroke
narco-epilepsy cataplexy
anaphylaxis acute mi myocarditis
infection
um pericarditis acute immune disease and
death
pregnancy and
birth outcome
syndrome in children
oh i'm sorry i missed that take that out
other acute
myelitis diseases non
anal
non
reaction
non-reactions such as anaphylactic shock
thrombocytopenia which is bleeding
disseminated
coagulation which is a clot venous
thrombo embolus which is plot you can
also get
arthritis and
joint pain
and kawasaki's disease in children and
multiple inflammatory syndrome in
children
this affects children a lot
as a reference to all these side effects
in meredith we have i know three people
who've had a bad reaction
from the visa
one is a friend of mine who got a
microclot
in his eye in a small vessel and is now
blind
the other two
um
had um
chickenpox virus and i'm sure there's
much more in merit that have been
affected but i don't know of them but
i'm probably sure
um i just read that the cdd cdc is
putting in a blood center in
five to six year old kids so that they
can get vaccinated
and what do they think will be be the
side effect bleeding if it's not
clotting it's bleeding from these
gene therapy i don't like to call it a
vaccine because it really isn't a
vaccine
why would the cdc give young children a
blood thinner
why in heaven's name would they do this
to our children
this is a red flag
for all parents
and teenagers who have already had the
shot and had these problems such as
pericarditis
and
all heart diseases you know they what's
happening i don't understand it why are
they doing this to our children
um the dose has been decreased for
children
why wasn't it for the the
the decrease for the teens
why not
and for the young
why wasn't it um
oh i forgot to say pericarditis and well
now
all these children and i read that um a
five
and a six-year-old in indiana was
mistakenly given
the
adult vaccine dose instead of the flu
shot
both those children are cardiac
compromised now
and they're only three and five
um so what's going to happen with these
kids and these teens you know what is
going to happen to them they're going to
be they're going to be
a cardiac individ
invalid for the rest of their lives
these crimes are against humanity i
really don't understand
that at all
why the cdc can even give us and tell us
what to do they're not the government
um i want to read something else what
they're doing with the infants the
national institute of health
approved a 3 million grant to the
university of pittsburgh for inducing
labor
on full-term pregnant women
and then removed organs from the fetuses
for the school's tissue bank
the truth is always more bizarre than
fiction this and according to the
medical records obtained
the university of pittsburgh medical
search team
will would take full
term pregnant women and induce them only
to then take their baby organs for sale
studies show that the university
would take unborn babies from six weeks
to 42 weeks remove their organs and then
proceed to place the organs in the
school's tissue bank
where they would
put them in the vaccines or whatever
they want to do is it's disgraceful
these universities are disgraceful i
have a couple of other things
but i think they've been mentioned
already
menticide
means the killing of the mind
priming society begins with fear using
waves of terror which is propaganda
which promotes confusion and helps to
break down the mind the big lie is
emotional
use they use contradictory reports to
confuse which descends into total terror
tele i'm having trouble with that word
total terror
totalitarian so um i thank you for your
time
and um hopefully you will put i know
you've got a lot of laws already
you know ready to set and discuss but i
hope
in my heart and soul and that you will
take the right step and
do more with the bill about the vaccine
in the first place
because it is very
it's not
all pertinent to what's happening so i
thank you very much
thank you rosemary any questions for
rosemary thank you for all you do
would you be willing to uh take a
question
uh representative elaine go ahead um
thank you for
i'm good thank you for bringing
attention to the recent fda approval of
pradaxa which is a novel anticoagulant
for children
are you aware that that's actually for
kids that have mechanical heart valves
and other things that otherwise are on
warfarin
i know it's i know it seems sinister but
there's a good medical use no i think
there are children that are on it who
are compromised
because i worked in pediatrics in boston
in my training
and um but they are going to give it
giving it to healthy kids that's the
problem
i don't see any of that in the approval
but thank you oh i do have that um
i can send you stuff
thank you
all right so a couple more speakers
again if we can keep the testimony to
under 10 minutes preferably around five
that would be really appreciated um
patricia myers
is patricia here
go ahead ma'am
i spoke monday again lift that
microphone up so it's pointing straight
at your mouth there you go sorry i was
here monday i wasn't particularly
articulate but a couple of things i want
to get out of the way first um
i don't i take exception to be referred
to as anti-vaxx i am not anti-vaxx
i've had more vaccinations than most of
you in this room unless you were in the
military
um
i am
pro-health
and to coin a phrase pro-life
as far as the controversy against
vaccinations
do you remember the anthrax vaccine
that came out in the 80s and 90s
my husband was in the military and he
had that
and he had complications in the military
you do not tell them i am not taking a
vaccine they will discharge you
dishonorably
and the other issue as far as
information on these things there is a
website
frontlinedoctors.com they have a very
comprehensive
um
informational site
the other one is um you can look up
vanderbosh
he is one of the developers of the
vaccine
and he is one of the people who are
telling us not to take it
he knows what's in it he made it
okay
the crux of my
uh testimony this morning is that this
is not the issue
covid anything associated with it is not
the issue
you have several bills pending about
covid why do we need so many bills
in my opinion there are way too many
bills on the books they should be burned
they're expensive to bring forward
and they very rarely
end up what they were intended to do
you heard testimony about the um
the language saying only covet is
protect uh people
you should change the language to all
medical procedures not just covet that's
one of the things that happens with our
laws i know i read them and i'm very
good with grammar
my premise is that we should go back to
the original laws
the constitution
of this state
the biblical laws which are even higher
love god with all your heart mind soul
and might then you won't be
as
inclined perhaps to
cave
the next one love your neighbor as
yourself
and i understand some of us may not love
ourselves very well so that might hinder
how we love others but to make it
clearer do unto others as you would have
them do unto you
do no harm to your neighbor
i am christian obviously
that's supposed to be a warm fuzzy thing
but even christ made a whip
and chased out those who defiled his
father's house
and made no mistake
these houses are gods
anyway
the
legislature of this state is supposed to
protect the interests of the people that
it serves
and i will say right now that there are
members here who do that
admirably so and i respect them for that
our state
is not obliged to bow down to the
federal government that is why we make
laws to stop the encroachment of that
government
the issue is
the corruption the broken system that's
what the issue is
the issue is taking money
and then voting
on issues that affect the people who
gave this the money
the issue is
an executive
chief
who puts his police force to an open
shame by having people arrested for
nothing more
than that they were too enthusiastic in
their recitation of the pledge of
allegiance
right now the way i see it
this state
has been in the process of being sold to
the highest bidder
it is time for that to stop
it is your job to enforce the checks and
balances that the founders put in place
to ensure that these assaults
go no further on our freedoms
thank you
thank you very much patricia
so apparently we have another group of
i'm assuming students
that's coming to the state house from uh
virginia where where we have people from
today
welcome to the state house guys welcome
to the house of representatives here in
front of the committee that's examining
the policy of medical interventions and
immunizations it was a study committee
that came out of house bill 220 which
was a bill that
restricted government from creating
certain side of coveted passports and
that those kind of things
and this study committee came out of
that we're hearing public testimony
today
on the topic of medical interventions
and immunizations and how it relates to
state and federal policy so thank you
again for coming we appreciate you i
hope you guys enjoy the tour
so we have two more speakers we have jay
is is island
um to speak is jay here
so jay you spoke on monday so i'm going
to ask you to limit your your
your speech yeah i think i gave you 10
minutes on monday i'll give you another
five minutes today to speak
go ahead sir
yeah my name is jay island
i am presently residing in lyndonville
vermont
but
i'm really from new hampshire i grew up
in new hampshire
i have new hampshire values
i don't like what i'm seeing all around
this nation
i have this nation's values
i
have lived most of my life working in
human services
i am also
my other
true self is
i am an artist and i am a writer
okay well i've written a piece for today
i have a quote here
dr peter mcculloch
author of the first and only
peer-reviewed covid19 disease treatment
protocol
the only one
very much unlike dr fauci's
i might add
he says due to viral loads the vaccines
do not provide any safety
in terms of
protect your loved ones
okay
my aim here is to cut through some of
the dead wood in the discussion
although hundreds of thousands of
americans are this fall lining up before
committees
and school boards
and exposing the coveted plandemic fraud
and corruption a thousand times over
the committees sit there in their seats
and shuffle papers around
then go home to their complacent non-fbi
violated homes
virtually nothing is being done by u.s
state or local committees in response to
the grievances about the covid fraud
i hope that i'm understating that so
sorry if i am you know
i hope you folks are different
all this mirrors what's going on in
other countries those countries were
never really free
but the us is acting just like them now
there's no difference now except a bit
of severity which we
are still spared temporarily millions
and millions of concerned citizens of
other nations are rising up around the
world and calling out the tyranny
demanding that it end
but there is zero responsiveness to the
the people's movement around the world
only crushing force in return by their
governments the police with expressions
of boredom complacency and cold power on
their faces carry out the abominable
deeds
and support them
just the same as in america in new
hampshire you have whistleblower therese
grinnell being arrested and charged with
the crime of saying amen to the phrase
under god in the pledge of allegiance
or the crime of endeavoring to keep
illegal meetings with illegal votes from
happening can this kind of travesty of
justice be tolerated not on my watch
the attitude by officials employers
anyone holding a position of relative
power seems to be
it's not our job to actually do
something substantial about this it's
not our department
it's as if all of us were born in early
20th century berlin or in bavaria
in reality it is one's responsibility
and is one's department when fraud and
crime are being committed to act
strongly or to do
what the very least one can to call it
out and to refrain from cooperating with
it no matter what position one is in
fraud and crime the president of the
united states commits the prime of com
crime of completely abandoning
separation of powers by acting as a
dictator handing down covet decrees
while calling them rules
how many people fully call this what it
is the end of the u.s yes legal
objection
are raised by the administration
legal objections are race but the
administration is confident they will
amount to nothing
this is the end of the us unless we the
people and you the members of this
committee take strong action
fraud and deception the media speaks in
a single mouthpiece voice with the
government declaring absurdly that a
vaccine that should have been banned a
hundred times over by now is safe and
effective we have no media it is in the
hands of mobsters the mainstream media
accuses its victims of misinforming
everyone which is in fact its own hard
and fast rule
airline pilots take the vacci
vaccination and then when they get up to
altitude in their plane they get tunnel
vision and they barely get the plane
down to the ground and can't remember
how they did it the same thing happens
to truck drivers one could go on and on
but the real point is it's a weapon
but the media tells us this is not
happening
jay down to 30 seconds
dwight eisenhower warned us of the
military industrial complex how
pertinent his warning becomes today
robert kennedy jr has delved into some
of the history of the cia how it was
initially established as an espionage
organization tasked solely with
intelligence gathering only to transform
into a paramilitary agency engaged with
the overthrowing of democracies around
the world and other nefarious and any
democratic activities
this transformation is globalist
imperialist in nature
cia's project mockingbird seems to have
never ended mockingbird appropriately
named is of course a program in which
the media is infiltrated by covert
agencies
february 10 2021 instagram banned the
account of acclaimed health researcher
robert f kennedy jr for sharing debunked
claims about the coronavirus or vaccines
as edward curtin put it in an off
guardian article
for all practice practical purposes when
it comes to matters that bear on
important foreign and domestic matters
the cia and the corporate mainstream
media cannot be distinguished
dr joseph
mercola states in the past year even
licensed licensed medical doctors and
award-winning scientists have undergone
the modern version of being tarred and
feathered online followed by expulsion
from their web-based communities for the
crime of asking common sense questions
and speaking truth to power
jake this is this is not to mention
being attacked
by members of their own medical
societies who wish to go along to get
along
jay so
it sounds like you're reading your
testimony and you have a written copy
which we're happy to take for the
committee but we're at a time for for
again this is your second second speech
well sir i
i beg your consideration because
um
you know
another thing that's happening and has
been happening for quite a number of
years in these committee hearings
is that the time people are given in
which to express what they have to say
is not adequate
and uh
and indeed uh
often
the people who want to speak don't even
get to speak unfortunately that's not
the case here so i i beg your indulgence
a little further how much more time do
you think you need
uh just
just about five more minutes
go ahead
okay
uh kurt edward curtin continues just the
other day the new york times had this
end line
robert kennedy jr barred from instagram
over false virus claims notice the lack
of the word alleged before false
virus claims in the new york times
this is guilt by headline it is a
perfect piece of propaganda posing as a
reporting since it accuses kennedy a
brilliant and honorable man
of falsity and stupidity thus justifying
in instagram's ban
and it it is an inducement further
censorship of mr kennedy by facebook
instagram's parent company this is one
example of the censorship underway with
much much more to follow what was once
done on the cover of emission omission
is now done openly and brazenly cheered
on by those who in an act of bad faith
claim to be upholders of the first
amendment and the importance of
a free debate in a democracy
we are quickly slipping into an unreal
totalitarian social order
end of curtain quote
fraud and crime the definition of
terrorism is simply to terrorize the
public for political ends such
terrorizing is precisely what has been
going on especially over the past two
years at
the hands of the globalist controlled
entity that once was the legitimate
united states our beloved nation's
political center has become an actual
terrorist extremist government accusing
its own citizens of its very own crimes
in this saul alinsky style technique
anyone that disagrees with the
government is unbelievable now labeled a
domestic terrorist
i a citizen i'm here to tell you that
such orwellian action in the u.s simply
cannot be abided or tolerated for an
instant you members of this very
committee cannot let this continue to
happen you cannot
fraud by a corrupt interest
in december 2020 dr pierre cory was
invited to testify to congress he did so
proving to congress that ivermectin's
zinc vitamin d treatment entirely
eradicates the risky or deadly features
of copendine teen disease including its
very transmission from person to person
corey's written testimony
containing evidence from over 25 studies
was ignored and even scorned
by
members of congress because the plan to
enact the vaccines has been set in stone
from a very long way back and billions
of dollars weren't are still involved
fraud and corruption
cdc and fda pretends that the approved
comarnati vaccine is the same as the now
brand-name vaccine being dispensed
that's for liability reasons
fraud and crime it has been discovered
that some batches of the covet vaccines
are extremely poisonous while other
batches are much less so in legitimate
medicine that situation would cause an
immediate halt to the vaccine program
has the program been halted no it is
pushed harder than ever
fraud and medical
result of the malpati administered
kobit-19 vaccines that's according to
the hugely under-reported cdc bears data
even a few years ago if such a disaster
had occurred the entire program would
have been halted instantly and
permanently
medical fraud and malfeasance in study
of pregnant women the nih is reputed to
have monetary interests
via patents in the vaccines the
pregnancy study by the nih completed
june 2021 was called preliminary
findings of mrna covet 19 vaccine safety
in pregnant persons
the result of it was that more than 8
out of 10 women in the study who could
have a miscarriage
had one
the authors of the study did everything
in their power to commit fraud by hiding
this result
the shocking result was hidden
fraudulently within the very time frames
in the study for technically early
births resulting in death are only
called miscarriages if they are before
the 20th week
but the study hid its own results by
doing the figuring as if all the women
had started the study close to the
beginning of their pregnancy whereas
actually only small percentage of them
had done that in this way
the deeply disturbing miscarriages in
this
in this small subgroup were falsely
given the statistical number of
individual setting of the entire group
rather than naturally using the number
of individuals in the small early term
group in the study the only group which
was even capable of technically having
any miscarriage abnormal early delivery
in later pregnancy terms goes by other
names than miscarriage
faced with enemies if we have stood up
if we stood on the new jersey or north
carolina shore around 1943 watching an
oil tanker ship go by on the horizon the
ship might suddenly have exploded
sending a huge cloud of giant fragments
of ship into the air would we in the
newspapers
weirdly and twistedly say about this
event oh some patriotic domestic
terrorist must have endangers us all
by lighting a cigarette on that tanker
causing it to blow up
or instead would we
would we in legit newspapers have
realized using common sense oh another
german submarine has struck our nation
with a torpedo
of course it was a torpedo by germans
they wished us
harm this is exactly the situation we
find ourselves in today we are being
attacked yes but not by our loyal
american fellow citizens to get us to
suspect or frame them as we are
encouraged and even
ordered to do is like
the strange idea of suspecting a
terrorist cigarette smoker on the 1943
oil tanker
so the ludicrous planted idea pushed by
mockingbird media today that we the
people are the enemy
is a ruse
the interests that are attacking us are
non-american and they are super
elite interests
and i just want to close
by saying
and reminding
everyone present
and thank you for others who have
invoked our divine father
i
i want to remind everyone that
our constitutions the state and the
national constitution
are firmly
based
on the principles of the ten
commandments
including the principles of thou shalt
not covet
thy neighbor's goods
thy neighbor's house possessions and so
forth
we see a society coming in that is the
opposite of that
i
saw a hearing of
san diego california school board i
believe it was the people came up
before the committee they were given
almost no time to speak
they were very very wealthy people they
were very very impressive and they bring
up all kinds of
of really strong points
but i see very little mention
of the lord who created us
and without this recognition
we are really cooked
because i i am certain that the lord who
created us is not happy
with with what's going on
and especially with the lack of
repentance
on the part of all of us in the american
public
of our once christian-based nation even
the principle
of separation of church and powers is
directly from jesus christ
my kingdom is not of this world
so
with that
i thank you so much and i'm so glad that
i'm not
in
the vermont
house right now
where there is very very little chance
of being genuinely and sincerely heard
and i thank you so much
and the state of new hampshire and i i
thank the lord jesus christ in the
in his name
amen
thank you jay
hey jay i know you were jay
jay i know you were reading from your
testimony if you could submit that that
would be really helpful for the
committee members to be able to see if
you could submit that either by email or
if you want to give what you have
written there to representative leon she
can add that to make sure it's clearly
in the record for anybody to read in the
future
kathleen
okay so i'll move on um elliott axelman
oh you ready kathleen oops sorry ellie
what do you hold on one second go ahead
kathleen
go ahead ma'am
good morning
i want to start by
thanking god and my lord and savior
jesus christ
that we're all able to be here this
morning exercising
our rights our right of freedom of
speech
and
our rights that are god-given
unleashable they cannot be taken away
they cannot be sold they cannot be
traded they cannot be lost they cannot
be given away
they cannot
and
i see
pretty much everything that's happening
around the
government
intrusion into our health especially
around this covid
treatment and so forth is a complete
violation of our rights violation of our
fourth amendment right to begin with
and
i see the world around us
and i think i don't think there's
anybody that would dispute this
i see the world around me and us turning
very hellish
why is that
the bible tells us that
the wicked and the nations that forget
god
are turned into hell and i say that's
exactly what's happening
and we as jay said we have a chance now
we have a chance thank you god we have a
chance to repent which means to turn
from our wicked ways and turn toward god
and that's for everybody i'm not really
just speaking to you folks it's to me
it's to all of us
and
so there are some very very brave people
physicians and highly credentialed
credible physicians all around the world
too many to to mention
i'm just going to mention a few of them
jay mentioned pierre quarry
and his testimony before congress that
ivor mexton is the
there's been 61 studies done worldwide
at this point that prove peer-reviewed
studies
that prove that ivermectin is
almost 100 percent effective in treating
covid especially when given as effective
early outpatient
treatment did you know
that 99
of the deaths from colvin occur where
anybody know
in hospitals why
could it be because they're given rem
deserver which is a is a disastrous drug
that does in the kidneys
and floods the lungs with fluid and then
they're put on a
ventilator
um i'll tell you what zeb zolenko has to
say about this dr zev zelenko in an
interview by the way i've sent you
videos and documentation of everything
that i'm saying
dr zebzalenko who has been effectively
treating covid
since the get-go effectively treating it
in an interview i think it was a couple
days ago basically said
that what's going on with covet and the
treatment of it right now is
pre-meditated first-degree murder
and genocide
of at least 750 000 americans i think
he's being kind there because it's
worldwide
um
so that's to be paid attention to i mean
we
what what is this are we living in nazi
germany right now i don't i don't think
so i think this is nazi germany on
steroids
in the 1930s
people
kind of would they would turn their head
the other way they were afraid to speak
up they didn't speak up while their
grandmothers and their children were
carted off to auschwitz
to be gassed to death what are we doing
now
what is the general public doing now
they've been very in a very
sophisticated
manner it seems that they've been mind
controlled and brainwashed i mean it has
to be something like that plus the
forgetting of god
and the love of truth
it has to be something like that because
people won't talk about it
our nation has been very deliberately
divided this the whole thing that's
going on this coveted thing is one big
piece of a much larger puzzle of the
intentional deliberate long-term
takedown and coupe of the united states
of america
the greatest nation on the upon the
earth why
because we are and we were the last
bastion of freedom
for the rest of the world are we just
going to sit here and do nothing
and let
the whole world
go you know where are we no
not as jason not on my watch not on our
watch
we love this nation we love what god
gave us thank you god the very values
and principles upon which this nation is
founded are reflections of the very
values of god himself
and we are duty-bound to stand up for
those to stand up for truth and what is
right and good
so
in sweden
they didn't mask
they didn't social distance what's the
other thing that everybody's doing they
they did none of that
and they have 1.8 million children
and zero deaths from covid
isn't that interesting
but of course we won't hear about that
on mainstream media i suggest that
anybody who's still watching mainstream
media
or listening to the
hypnotic
droning voices of npr
national
propaganda radio that you shut those
things off if you're still buying into
the lies
you've please i please god help
everybody that is buying into laws open
their eyes and remove the scales from
our eyes
open our hearts lord help us to to see
what's really going on and to stand up
against it
dr michael yaden
the former vice president of of pfizer
and at that time he was their chief
medical scientist
says that for every listen to this this
is really important
he he's a man of
undeniable credibility
he says that for every one child
that dies from coved guess how many
would die from the vaccine
100.
now
what kind of odds is that to to march
your child off to
to get their vaccine oh but guess what
you don't have to march your child off
anymore because the who says
that
just sending your child to public school
or to any school
um
implies consent
now how insane is that
i mean really who who would who would go
along with this well the who would and
who do they think they are
suddenly
people are
falling down all over the place and
lapping up the most absurd things like
the fact that thinking that the who
has any kind of authority whatsoever or
that the state does to tell you what to
do with your children
really and
other other
sources of
authority that people are just lapping
up oh bill gates let's see he's not a
doctor he has his finger in every pie
he has been into eugenics and
depopulation for decades
and has stated pretty strongly about re
reducing the world population by 10 to
15 that's probably it's probably being
understated when he says that but
everybody just totally accepts that he
has his finger in every pie
and looks the other way so anyway all of
this is a is part of destabilizing
demoralizing
this nation
to
bring us down so they can bring in
tyrannical beyond tyrannicals it's it's
germany
in the 1930s on steroids folks
we have to wake up to that
um
so
even if this vaccine were perfectly
wonderful government has no right to
mandate that or anything else like the
masks the lockdowns those are that's
totally completely a violation of our of
our constitutional rights
people in general would comply
on their own if they wanted to but we
will not
comply
to
the absurd and
genocidal things that are happening in
this nation no we will call them out
as we're doing here today and and on
tuesday
so
as a nation
we're we're in tough shape we're in
tough shape you know
what did ben franklin say to the woman
who said do you have a was it a monarchy
or a republican he said a republic man
if you can keep it can we keep it
with god's help i think that's the only
way
you know
one minute
i guess two more things to say
where there is the spirit of the lord
there is liberty
without it forget it
so
king asa in second chronicles chapter 14
verse 11
was going out to battle against
unimaginable odds which is what we're up
against it's
like nothing that's ever been seen on
the face of the earth before
and
he was told by a prophet that he had to
always ask for god's help and not to
rely on himself or other people it's not
like we we really have to do everything
we can do everything
but he cried out to the lord
and asa cried unto under his god and
said lord it is nothing would be to help
whether with many or with them that have
no power help us o lord our god for we
rest on thee and in thy name we go
against this multitude o lord thou art
our god let not man prevail against thee
and i ask this in the name of jesus
christ
thank you so much for listening i really
appreciate that we have the opportunity
to do this and i pray that you all
um
contemplate deeply that this is a deep
spiritual matter
that we're dealing with it's
individually we all
i'm no different than you guys or
anybody else we are all facing huge
spiritual inward battles may god help us
thank you kathleen
our last speaker of the day will be
elliot axelman
again elliott because you've already
spoken months before you have no more
than five minutes yes sir thank you
thanks for having me back
so according to the inflated statistics
uh
the highest amount of children that have
died of covet over the past year year
and a half
is right around 200 so i thought it was
going to be a lot more because of all
the propaganda that even i believed a
little bit i thought it was going to be
in the thousands but i looked at all the
stats the aap the cdc right now 200 250
under 21 year olds have died in the last
two years
um and because of that number around 200
kids have died of kovid we shut down the
world like never before in history first
time in history of existence that i know
we shut down schools locked kids up in
houses and and put masks on them and now
we're forcing vaccines on them so um you
know if that's reasonable which almost
every politician in the world believes
that that was reasonable i think that
it's also reasonable to
uh do every single mitigation strategy
for everything that kills more than 200
kids so if let's say there was something
out there that killed 300 or 500 kids a
year we should take every single
precaution necessary even if it means
disrupting other uh quality of life
so for instance
chronic lower respiratory diseases kill
274 kids a year so to stop all chronic
respiratory lower disease like copd or
in kids uh maybe cf or other lung
disease let's ban all smoking mandate
air purity filters in every single boom
in the entire united states and let's
ban all e-cigarettes and vaping
340 kids die every year of fires and
burns you know fires and burns and ems
it is very very rare but 340 so more
than covet kids die from fires and burns
i think that you guys should propose a
bill next year or amend one of the bills
because too late for this year amend the
bill to mandate every room in new
hampshire have at least one fire
extinguisher and maybe even mandate
every kid walk around 24 7 and fire
proof fire retardant clothes um because
that would save 340 lives uh 599 kids
every year diet heart disease it's
probably congenital heart disease um 979
die from congenital anomalies
982 die from drug overdose and poisoning
let's ban all poison substances
995 almost a thousand way more than
coven die from drowning i think we
should uh ban all pools in new hampshire
let's propose a bill to ban all pools um
i got rid of my pool so i'm doing my
part and let's mandate water wings
floatation devices on every kid below 21
years old 24 7 to walk around in case
they drown because again that would save
more lives than all the mitigation for
kobe right so uh 1430 over a thousand
kids die of suffocation from choking on
things every year so um let's ban kids
from eating small things i guess and
let's mandate that every single group in
new hampshire
have uh a device to get something out of
someone's throat like a life back or
maybe advanced area equipment like
intubation or uh other mcgill forceps or
something like that what else um oh
malignant neoplasm so cancer kills 1800
as we know there are things we do to get
rid of cancer and over 3 000 kids die in
firearm related injuries let's uh bail
all guns i guess
so i guess all firearms have to be
banned if we're going to do everything
to save kids because again it would save
kids lives and over 4 000 kids die every
year the number one killer of kids every
year is motor vehicle accidents again
ems for 10 years i've had a lot of
motivated classes i've treated yes we
all know kids do die from it so let's
ban anyone from under 21 years old from
being in a car um or you know mandate
more air bags or let's pass more laws of
mandating uh maybe five seat belts like
a harness or race car drivers and a
helmet whenever kids are in a car
because again that would save four
thousand lives and if we're gonna turn
flip the world like we all know we shut
down the world for a year two years like
we've never done before in history of
humanity for to save the max potential
benefit was saving around 200 lives a
year and again every life is important
every death is a tragedy if we're going
to shut down the world and crash the
world economy biggest crash in the stock
market in the world economy in history
of existence so that the whole uh united
states and world markets crashed if
we're gonna do that for to save 200
lives to save four thousand lives we
should bail cars so again even if
there's a cost to the mitigation the
cost is worth the benefit but definitely
banning all cars and banning all
firearms banning all foods that cause
cancer and heart disease and all the
other things
uh mandating flow changing
device for every kid 24 7. that would
save you know hundreds maybe a few
thousand more lives so i i'm expecting
to see all those bills proposed next
year so thank you
thank elliot i'm assuming a lot of that
was sarcasm but um
is there any questions for elliott
thank you
last night
right that concludes uh all of the
speakers that have asked that asked to
speak or any other anybody else in the
hall who'd like to speak
yep you can ask a question go ahead
okay i i have a question did not the
governor
nullify the emergency situation in new
hampshire or am i wrong
so i think if your question is around
the current mandates through executive
order and the uh the osha rule that was
the emergency osha rule that was
released the state of new hampshire did
john on joining on to a federal lawsuit
that federal lawsuit has
the judge has issued an injunction
stopping that stopping the um uh
executive orders and the osha rules from
going into effect so the best thing i
can say right now is that the on the
federal mandate side there's currently a
pause in play that uh good in new
hampshire in new hampshire and in
closing why are they promoting the
vaccines then
okay it's not about it's not about
promoting the vaccine it's about
mandates so there's a difference there's
a differential between those two things
do you agree you can a public health
official would say they believe that
vaccines are good but there's a
difference between saying public
vaccines are good and you must get a
vaccine those are two different
statements don't you agree one involves
choice one involves no choice and the
the fact that the injunction is in play
the the which had which was against the
executive order for federal contractors
and people
and the uh osha rule which gave no
choice well that's the latest that's the
injection the injunction is currently in
place
so the injunction is current in play for
that
i'm sorry so the injunction has stopped
that those that osha rule and the
executive order are currently in in
effect
okay um also
i wanted to say that i heard on the
internet that there were
800 000 children between the ages of 5
and 11 that have already been
got the gene vaccine
in the in the united states
and also
i wanted to add that when the university
of pittsburgh
takes these babies from the mother's
womb
and their their full term babies
when they take the organs out of the
out of the baby the baby is
awake and going through pain screaming
and crying
and
they only do this because they want to
preserve the blood flow to the organs
so that the organs can be sold
and i think that's despicable
i mean it's just inhuman
so i wanted to clarify that
and um
how does this committee
um
are the is the public gonna hear from
all the people that have written in
somehow
because this is public viewing so most
of the emails
so most of the emails have been
forwarded to the committee staffer
that's managing the um
uh docket if you will right the the
paper papers we get from citizens go to
that go to that person and they put it
in the record
excuse me in the file for the for the
bill
so all of them be available to um
to be read if somebody wants to at some
point i think they do digitize them and
put them online i'm not positive of that
i'll be honest with you i hope they do
that because i would like to read
i'm sure as you can imagine we have lots
of emails on this topic um and so it
will be a pretty significant stack
and that that record is also used as
part of the court system so if someone
was to challenge the law they would go
back to see what was submitted and what
was presented before the committee and
they'd be able to read all those topics
so again we've we've forwarded uh
as many uh many of the emails through
and i have more i've gotten this morning
while we didn't have testimony which
i'll forward to the committee
researchers should be added to the the
folder for our record so yes that
information it will be made ultimately
available for the public
okay so if i come next week i'll be able
to read some of their emails i will i
don't know what their timeline is to get
that digitized and into the system i
have no idea
again the vast majority of emails at
least i've received are opposing the any
any mandates um and there's been a very
limited number of emails i've received
that support the mandate okay thank you
for your time and service
sure step up to mike rowan if you have a
question for the committee
record i want to ask
the whole committee each and every one
of you
you're under oath correct you took an
oath to serve we the people correct
yes that's a standard yes
every ops every every person takes
questions
if
an experimental drug or a vaccine
if you want to call it that
if it is fda approved
and this is a yes or no
answer
do all ingredients
have to be public
yes or no
all ingredients are public
so they have to be public to be
approved fda okay
so we need transparency on that and
someone's saying that it is
public so it
confuses me how we are
even questioning or voting on a mandate
of a bio weapon
so
for the record
it is not a vaccine so let's be
transparent let's be honest to all
humanity please thank you
step up the mic one of you like to speak
thank you mr chairman i read that uh
rosenwald's is on this committee i'd
like to know if that's really true and
if if she is why she's absent today and
monday
i can't speak to why members did not
choose to attend the meeting i have no
idea i believe she's traveling but i'm
not positive
so committee members are not required to
be at events like this community members
are appointed meetings are
are public and they're supposed to
attend it's all i can tell you okay
thank you
representative horgan oh thank you um
first of all uh it's not uncommon
especially for senators there's 24 of
them and there's many committees so
they're they're quite often not all of
them are here so that's
and also they're talking about the
digitization my understanding is i might
confuse the question if you prefer but i
think my understanding is that
in eventually everything that's
submitted to every community gets
digitized but there's a huge backlog so
it um hopefully you'll be digitized
right away but um we can't really count
on it and my question was well i brought
you the question why don't you mention
we were talking about some number 7000
from the cdc which you updated to 15
100 which i guess is still two percent
of what i the
total number of reported covet deaths is
but
i want to clarify at some point i don't
know where you can do it now exactly
which what that number was and where i
can find it in the cdc reports i made an
effort
looking at my phone to find it and i
didn't know where to look for it so just
and that's probably something you should
many things you should put in the report
so
which comes out of december 1st
so they they answer your question the
data comes directly from the cdc website
from their their cumulative death
certificate
numbers and if you look at that it
breaks it down by state new hampshire
they reported 33 of those deaths that
were reported for covid were
self-afflicted injury injury or
poisonings were actually 33 of the
deaths in new hampshire reported under
that category
so that's a direct cdc statistical
number that you can look at and you want
to look at the um
conditions and the secretary of state's
office also has like a
the call the divide vital records
database which probably shows something
similar and
oh one more question um
so the
hb 220 i guess does um give you the
chance to introduce legislation after
the hearing and the report are done do
you have any intention of introducing
more legislation or you don't or is that
something
so as a study committee the committee
has the availability to um
request late drafting and and it's
routinely granted for late drafting of
bills but again as i spoke before we
have 32 bills on the on the various
topics we'd probably be more inclined to
recommend an amendment to an existing
bill to cover any of the um
at least i'm speaking for myself i'd be
more inclined to
recommend amendments to the bills that
are going in if we think there's a topic
that's come out of this committee that
needs
uh action and we we repurpose one of the
existing bills or add on to one of the
existing bills yeah good idea given
there's addition of those 32 bills
there's i think
842 other bills i think there's 77
[Music]
bills if i'm not mistaken all right
thanks thank you
further questions for the committee yes
one
real quick comment um
we hear a lot we've heard a lot this
morning about medical exemptions this
right here is our exemption
under the constitution which all swore
to uphold
we the people
thank you
hi um thank you for taking questions
this is so refreshing compared to school
board meetings
um
i have a question i don't have a copy of
the bill in front of me but i'm gonna
reference was stuck in my head when
another speaker spoke
um that the bill is in reference to
immunizations and medical interventions
would a medical intervention include the
masking because it's being used as a
medical device and give us back our
rights over our children's to use or not
use
a medical device in schools
being forced i'm going to pass this over
to erica uh representative leigh and i
think we had we had a definition in one
of the here one of the meetings they
talked about what medical intervention
was and talk about treatment and
procedures and i'm trying i don't recall
the exact language i used i'm hoping
maybe she remembers
there are many definitions of medical
interventions um there's more of a focus
on those that are invasive so they cross
the body barrier so whether it's an
injection whether it's a blood blood
draw whether it's something that goes
through a natural orifice
because it's a hard thing to define and
you have to draw a line at some point
and
at this point there is a difference
between something you can take off and
something that you can't
so is there anything
then coming down the pipeline to help
parents to get
that gain back control over our medical
decisions because right now the schools
are making medical decisions for our
children that many of us don't agree
with
there are several bills that have been
filed for that
thank you
any other questions
that the constitution is the highest law
in the land
and that our rights are unalienable and
so parents haven't lost their rights
they've given them up perhaps by not
knowing that they can't lose them and
that the rights are being
unconstitutionally violated and taken
from them they have not lost their
rights isn't that true
i i don't know how to answer your
question ma'am i'm sorry i don't know
how to answer your question so the
question is
that's probably the best answer i get i
don't know the answer to your question
well it would be good a really good
thing to look into because i know the
answer to the question well i can
probably tell you that the federal
lawsuit that's currently pending
asks that one of those exact questions
whether or not it's a fundamental rights
issue to begin with
the constitution means what it says
and we have not lost our rights okay
thank you
i just wondered how many members are on
this committee i see one two three
there's six is currently senator
rosenwald is the only one that's missing
okay all right thank you
last comment of the question of the day
so i have a child who is in her 30s
works at concord hospital
she
like me has co-morbidities
i will not be getting this shot
and i have my own personal reasons for
it and the constitution supports me in
that choice or it should
luckily i'm a housewife
so i'm not being mandated by my employer
or the state
but
my child who
works at concord hospital
was told by a certainty she had to
submit
an exemption or a you know something to
let them make the decision for her about
whether she was going to do this thing
medically she has comorbidities she
literally has half organs because i am
a type 1 diabetic and one of the things
that i passed on to my child
is the fact that she doesn't have all of
her organs
so
she had to
submit a medical exemption but she went
to her primary
in franklin
and
this doctor literally told her i cannot
write you a medical exemption or i will
lose my physician capability
i cannot do it
my over the people above the doctor are
telling her she can't have her job or
take care of her patients
if she writes my daughter
a reason to not medically get out of
this injection
wrong so wrong
but
so she decides since she's gone to the
doctor paid for a visit had her primary
and her have a full conversation where
the doctor is literally apologizing to
her that she can't do what she knows she
should do
because if she does it she's got no job
so my daughter walks out calls me after
and was like mom
she can't write me one what are you
talking about you have
half your organs she knows it's not safe
yeah my only other option is to do the
religious exemption
we are christian family we attend church
we have our beliefs from the bible so i
tell her well go ahead and try to submit
it she ends up leaving the hospital
because she's so afraid that on that day
that they're going to make her do it
then she looks for other work and i'm
telling her hold on
hold on because maybe this will all
change before that date comes right
so she submits for the religious
exemption
she leaves the hospital
luckily she had many opportunities
because she's a very good candidate in
her field to find other work
she found other work
that didn't require this to come down on
her
she leaves her job that she loved and
she goes to this other job
she's working it for a little while and
she gets the notification weeks later
that they've accepted her religious
exemption
oh well that first of all shouldn't have
been something she should have had to
submit in the first place because that
is an individual choice as well
i will tell you another thing that my
son attends the same district that you
live in and this morning i had to call
the principal of the winter squam middle
school and tell them my son will not be
attending school and that they had
better get him an education that is
adequate even though i'll be keeping him
home because he's not wearing a mask
because my son who will not be getting
this either over my dead body
had heart surgery at boston children's
at five days old i am not putting this
bio weapon
which we don't know what it does other
than the myocarditis which is
hugely
fearful for me
i've talked to my doctor about every
vaccine that my family has had raising
my daughter and raising my son i am not
an anti-vaxxer i've had all my vaccines
my son has attended public school he's
had all his vaccines that are mandated
for him to attack
from now on
he will be religiously exempting
out of any future vaccines from this
country that says that he should have
one
to attend school to attend anything
and i'm telling you that you guys need
to listen to your constituents all of
them not just the ones that are fearful
i'm fearful too but i had covet
i'm immune my child who worked at the
hospital had covered had to prove she
didn't that she was healthy and had the
strength to go back to work at that
hospital
and they still didn't take
anything but a religious exemption
as her reason for being now she's back
to work that she went back to the
hospital after all of that
they accepted her back gladly because
she was a good employee
i just you guys have got to look to
everybody for there's reasons people
don't do these things and you don't i
wouldn't take a vaccine if it was going
to mean that it was going to react
differently with my insulin because that
insulin keeps me alive
if i didn't have it in my body right now
i'd be dead right
you guys can't just
look at
one thing and think it's not okay if i
was an employed person and i chose to
not get it i i lose my house i lose
everything i've worked my whole life for
it's not okay
just okay
i'm sorry i got emotional but thank you
thank you for your testimony thank you
for your comment question so a real
question yes sir okay this time do you
guys have any idea who's going to be
held liable eventually when in a few
years inevitably um we have kids or
adults as well who have some mild to
moderate brain or other injuries from
chronic hypoxia which is low oxygen and
chronic hypercapnia which is high co2
there have been some studies of uh
chronic hypoxia in regards to copd and
overall it could uh increase hemoglobin
as well which can cause more clots but
also
overall if your oxygen saturation is a
little low not dying but if it's a
little like 90 95 90 85 you get some
brain fog and anxiety and eventually
some memory loss and from this two year
long experiment of wearing masks 24 7
and uh same with high co2 can also cause
a little bit of brain damage not like
super severe mr or whatever but it can
cause some memory loss anxiety some slow
reflexes and overall a little bit of
brain damage in a few years i'm afraid
we're going to see some of that because
not me but somewhere masks 24 7. and it
absolutely does decrease oxygen and 3
co2 you know who's going to be liable
will you be able to sue the government
for mandating and coercing us to take
you know put on masks or the school
boards or businesses you force masks so
that's my first question i'd love an
answer and the second one is is someone
mentioned that doctors are losing
licenses and you know some doctors
throughout the united states because of
the ama and all the board certifications
for attendings for different specialties
are revoking the uh board certifications
for doctors who don't speak highly
positively of the vaccine or who oppose
coronary fascism as a paramedic without
my paramedic card i can't earn money um
you know from being a medic do you do
you guys plan as state reps or other
state reps to revoke my license if i
don't endorse the vaccine or endorse
chronic fascism and that would take my
livelihood and that would be another
question i would love to answer for
thanks
sure so answer your two questions the
first one being is there several bills
submitted relative to liability uh on
covet and whether there's business
liability whether it's governmental
liability or whether there's individual
liability and where that i think there's
at least three bills on on um liability
as it relates to exposure to covid or
expo or the mandates that have been
pushed down
secondarily to answer your your second
question there
on the licensure so
um there's no bill somewhere that talk
about licensure for doctors relative to
being suspended so that would be a
policy or regulation that's dealt with
in the board of medicine um on their
regulatory requirements for um licensure
so but there are no currently no bills
to address that that i'm aware
all right that being done we're going to
go into recess
real quick uh but before the committee
members leave i guess i we're gonna meet
in in state house 103
uh how long do we want to take a break
for before we come back
i'm hoping we can have a good committee
work session and not be very long at all
i've i've worked up some draft language
i'll get printed out and so each member
has a copy of some draft language
and we can talk about the draft language
and see if there's anything that really
needs to be done um
yep so we're going to meet in state
house 103 we'll take a 15-minute break
to give us file break use the restroom
that kind of thing ten minutes ten
minute break so we'll meet down there at
12 10
in state house room 103 where the
committee will begin some deliberations
and discussions around the committee
report that'll be a result of this
hearing thank you god bless you
you